MORNING'S HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON JOBS
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN THE
ECONOMY FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE LEGISLATIVE
SESSION I AM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SABRINA CERVANTES SERVING AS
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE WITH ME
THIS MORNING ARE SEVERAL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
INCLUDING FROM MY LEFT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ED CHAU INTO MY RIGHT WE
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TASHA
BOERNER HORVATH AND WE ALSO
HAVE WITH THIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
THURSTON SMITTY SMITH. AND
VIRTUALLY WE DO HAVE JOINING US
TODAY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PARTY
PETRIE-NORRIS. TODAY WE HAVE A
COUPLE MEMBERS OF RELIGIOUSLY.
OUR STAFFING OUR CHIEF CAN.
WITH THE ASSEMBLY JOBS COME.
MISS TOURNEY SIGN AND ALSO OUR
CAUCUS. CAN TO- GINO R. J. GIL
KIAN WHO IS WHAT THE THIS. WE
DO HAVE OUR WORK ON- OCCUPYING
THIS MORNING WORSE FOR WHO IS
OUR CA SEX. PLEASE NOTE THAT
MERCEDES IS ABOUT TO. AND WHO'S
PROBLEMS CONNECTING WITH OUR
LIVE STREAM AND CALLING INTO
THE HEARING OR FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT SHE CAN BE REACHED AT
AREA CODE NINE ONE SIX THREE
ONE NINE TWENTY NINETY. JUST
BEFORE WE BEGIN I'D LIKE TO-
JUST PROVIDE A QUICK OVERVIEW
OF HOW THE PUBLIC WILL BE ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS HEARING
OF COURSE DUE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING GUIDELINES WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING IN PERSON. WE ARE ALSO
REQUIRING THAT MUST BE WORN AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCE SEEM BE
MAINTAINED BY EVERYONE IN THE
HEARING HEARING ROOM TODAY. FOR
THOSE WATCHING THE TEST THOSE
WHO WISHED PROTEST DURING
PUBLIC TESTIMONY PLEASE
REMEMBER THE NUMBER TO CALL IS
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE
TWENTY NINETY. AND MERCEDES
WILL BE AVAILABLE TO ASSIST YOU.
WE ANTICIPATE THAT AGENDA ITEM
FIVE THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
SHOULD BEGIN AROUND ELEVEN TEN
ELEVEN FIFTEEN AM. BUT I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A QUORUM NOW-
IF MISS SIMON'S IF YOU COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THANK YOU
FAIR CERVANTES HERE. THE BAD
DAYS HERE VICE CHAIR CUTTING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
HERE THAT'S THE SEVEN WERNER
HER HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAD
ASSEMBLY CHAD HERE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATCH NORRIS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROB US YOUR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HERE AS MEMBER OF SMITH
HERE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SOME. YOU
HAVE A QUORUM. SO TODAY'S
HEARING IS THE FIRST IN THIS
YEAR OF HEARING IN BRIEF FONG
BY ASSEMBLY J. COME WE WILL
EXAMINE CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR INCLUSIVE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY TO HELP FRAME
THIS HEARING IT LET US REMEMBER
THAT RESPONDING TO THE CORONA
VIRUS PANDEMIC HAS REQUIRED THE
STATE TO TAKE EXTREME AND RAPID
STEPS TO PROTECT THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
WITHIN ONE WEEK OF MARCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY THE STATE WENT
FROM OPEN FOR BUSINESS. TO
IMPLEMENTING A STRICT STAFF
HOME ORDER FOR EVERYONE NOT
DIRECTLY ENGAGED IN WHAT
GOVERNMENT CONSIDERED AN
ESSENTIAL AND CRITICAL BUSINESS
ACTIVITY SINCE MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY IT IS ESTIMATED THAT
MORE THAN TWENTY THOUSAND
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA HAS
SHUT THEIR DOORS PERMANENTLY
AND OVER THIRTEEN POINT NINE
MILLION UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
CLAIMS HAVE BEEN FILED WITH OUR
STATE EDT DEPARTMENT. THIS IS
RESULTED IN MORE THAN A AND
TWENTY. BILLION AND
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS BEING
PAID TO IMPACTED WORKERS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. AS WE
TRANSITION FROM OUR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE TO ECONOMIC RECOVERY
IT IS IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THE
LESSONS FROM THE GREAT
RECESSION. A RISING TIDE DOES
NOT LIFT ALL BOATS. LET US NOT
FORGET THAT EVEN WHEN
CALIFORNIA ENJOYED A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY STRAIGHT MONTH OF
ECONOMIC GROWTH FOLLOWING THE
GREAT RECESSION THERE WERE
SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC FORCES
DRIVING INCOME INEQUALITY. JUST
TO SHARE WITH YOU BETWEEN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE AND
THROUGH TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EARNINGS FROM THE TOP 001% OF
HOUSEHOLDS INCREASED BY MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED AND FORTY
THREE PERCENT. AS COMPARED TO
EARNINGS OF THE BOTTOM 90% OF
HOUSEHOLDS WHICH ONLY
EXPERIENCING. OF TWENTY TWO
POINT 2% GIVEN THESE DIVERGENT
INCOME OUTCOMES IT IS NOT
SURPRISING THAT CALIFORNIA HAS
RANKED PRIOR. RIGHT PRIOR TO
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC
WITHIN THE TOP TIER OF STATES
RELATIVE TO HOUSEHOLD POVERTY
THIS DOES NOT HAVE TO BE THE
CALIFORNIA STORY GOING FORWARD
WE NEED TO LEARN FROM THE GREAT
RECESSION AND THIS TIME WE CAN
BUILD BACK BETTER. AND BUILD
BACK STRONGER SO MY INTENTION
AND INITIATING THE SERIES OF
HEARINGS I REALLY CREATE A
PLATFORM BY WHICH THE ASSEMBLY
JOBS COMMITTEE CAN HEAR FROM
OUR STAKEHOLDERS. I WE TO TRACK
QUALITY RESEARCH ULTIMATELY
REALLY PUTTING FORTH A LIST OF
RECOMMENDATIONS SOUND
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE FEDERAL
AND STATE GOVERNMENTS- FOR
POSSIBLE ACTION MOVING FORWARD.
LET ME GO AHEAD AND SHARE WITH
YOU THREE ISSUES THAT ARE THAT
WILL BE DISCUSSED IN TODAY'S
HEARING THE FIRST ONE A CLOSE
UP OF THE TWO POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS SMALL GRANT PROGRAM
THAT WE JUST AUTHORIZED
YESTERDAY. SECOND A BRIEFING ON
CURRENT RESEARCH ON THE IMPACTS
OF KOBE NINETEEN ON SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THIRD A PANEL
SMALL BUSINESS STAKEHOLDERS TO
DISCUSS HOW THE STATE PROGRAMS
ARE DROPPING TO MEET SMALL
BUSINESSES. NEEDS DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. BEFORE I OPEN IT UP
TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT I WOULD LIKE TO.
ACTUALLY OUR VICE CHAIR
CURRENTLY ISN'T HERE WITH US
BUT LET ME GO AHEAD AND OPEN IT
UP TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
IF ANY MEMBERS WISH TO SAY A
FEW WORDS BEFORE WE BEGIN WITH
OUR FIRST. PERSON IF WE COULD
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER TOM WERNER
HARPER. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
IT'S GREAT TO BE A MEMBER OF
THIS COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING ME I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND HER STAFF
FOR WORKING SO HARD TO PUT
TOGETHER THAT THESE HEARINGS-
AS INDICATED IN THE REPORT THE
COMMITTEE PUT TOGETHER SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE AN INTEGRAL PART
OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY AND WE
KNOW THEY HAVE BEEN TRAGICALLY
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC. LAST
YEAR I WORKED WITH THE SPEAKER
THE CHAIR AND SEVERAL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES TO START THE WHEELS
IN MOTION ON POLICIES TO AID IN
RECOVERY BASEDON PROJECTIONS
AND ANALYSES WE COLLECTED FROM
RESEARCHERS FROM AROUND THE
STATE ABOUT WHAT THE IMPACT OF
CO NINETEEN LOOK LIKE ARE ALL
ON OUR ECONOMY. NOW THAT WE
HAVE DATA AND WE ARE SEEING
MORE OF THIS IMPACT IT'S
ESSENTIAL THAT WE LOOK
CAREFULLY AT WHICH BUSINESSES-
AND WHICH BUSINESS OWNERS HAVE
BEEN MARKED MOST EFFECTIVE HOW
THEY'VE BEEN AFFECTED. IN ORDER
TO MAKE OUR STATE'S RECOVERY
EFFORTS MOVING FORWARD MORE
EQUITABLE INCLUDING HOW THE TWO
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS AN
ADDITIONAL SMALL BUSINESS
GRANTS TO THE CHAIR MENTIONED-
R. O. B. REALLY HELPING OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES. HOW WE
RESPOND IN THE NEXT SIX MONTHS
IS CRITICAL TO DETERMINE THE
LENGTH OF THE DEPTH OF THE
ECONOMIC CHALLENGES THAT CODE
NINETEEN HAS CREATED. I LOOK
FORWARD TO THIS INFORMATIONAL
HEARING- I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
PANELISTS WERE ABOUT TO HEAR
AND HOW WE CAN HELP OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES IN OUR STATE WE
COVER A SOME OF THE EFFORTS
THAT ARE ALREADY UNDERWAY THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY JIM FROM. THANK YOU
MADAM AND THANK YOU- HAVING
THIS HEARING. TODAY AND
CERTAINLY FOLLOWING- YESTERDAY
AND THE APPROVAL OF. OF ITEMS
THAT WOULD- HELP IN IN GO TO-
HELP BUSINESSES- AND THE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. AND ESPECIALLY
WITH SMALL BUSINESSES CONTINUE
TO MOVE FORWARD. I KNOW WE
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
EASING SOME REGULATORY FEES ON
A CERTAIN INDUSTRY COSMETOLOGY
I BELIEVE YESTERDAY. BUT I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CONTINUE
TO HAVE THAT DIALOGUE- AND
FURTHER THAT DIALOGUE WITHIN
THESE HEARINGS THAT WE'RE
HAVING HERE TODAY. SO I WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT. WE CONTINUE
TO HAVE THAT LAND OR SUPPORT
TO- MADAM CHAIR. FOR ISSUES ARE
COMING UP WITH ENJETI THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WISH TO. HAVE
A FEW WORDS SOME MEMBER. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR OF THE YOU FOR
OF ALLOWING US TO SERVE THIS
ONE I LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH
ALL OF. TO GET CAL BACK TO WITH
STIMULUS OF THE WAS APPROVED
YES ON THE FOR. I THINK IT'LL
GO A LONG WAY TO HELPING OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES. BUT- WE NEED
TO GET. ALL BUSINESSES BACKING.
OPENED UP. AN OPEN UP SAFELY.
AND NOT TAKEN THOUGH. BIG FIRST
ARREST FORCE- MOMENT POP DRY
CLEANER SHOP SO I LOOK FOR TO
WORKING ALL OF YOUR- TO OPEN UP
GOT. SAFE WITH A GETS A
RESOURCE TO THIS BUSINESS. THAT
MAKES THAT THEY CAN OPEN SO
WITH THANK YOU. HELLO SIR GO
HEAD TO ONE ME ASK JUST COVER
ONE. ITEM FOR THOSE WHO TO
SPEAK DURING THE PUBLIC. PERIOD
I ITEM. PLEASE USE THIS TO IN
EIGHT SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS THIRTEEN. FIFTEEN FORTY
TWO OH TO- FOR PLANNING
PURPOSES WE DO ANTICIPATE
PUBLIC COMMENT AROUND ELEVEN
FIFTEEN AM. I THE COMMITTEES
ALSO ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH MARCH
FIFTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
AND JUST TRY TO BEGIN DAYS YOU
THAT WE ARE GOING TO GO A
LITTLE OUT OF ORDER TO
ACCOMMODATE FOR OUR NEXT
SPEAKER- AMONG THE INFORMATION
YOU DO HAVE IS AN OVERVIEW OF
THE STATE ECONOMY AND HOW
COPING NINETEEN IS AMPLIFYING
INCOME INEQUALITY IN
CALIFORNIA. YOU HAVE A SPECIAL
APPENDICES ON SMALL BUSINESSES
ARE RELATED TO BUDGET ACTIONS
AND THE REPORTS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS SUBMITTED BY
STAKEHOLDERS PRIOR TO THIS- BUT
IF OUR- NEXT SPEAKER I CAN TAKE
A MOMENT TO OPEN THEIR VIDEO
AND AUDIO STUDYING. I LET ME
QUICKLY PROVIDE A BRIEF
FRAMEWORK- AND THE AGENDA ITEM
AS WE GET- THAT HAVE BEEN
ROLLING HERE. BIRDS WERE GONNA
HEAR A GENDER ITEMS. I IN ORDER
TO GET A COMEDY OR SENIOR. AND
AT MYERS SCHEDULE. I KNOW THAT
WE ARE VERY. IN HEARING FROM
HER ABOUT THIS BUSINESS COMPANY
RELIEF CREDIT AND HOW IT FITS
WITHIN THE GUY. BROADER I CAN.
RECOVERY STRATEGY. LET ME GO
AHEAD AND SEE DIRECTOR MYERS IS
AVAILABLE. TO BEGIN. THANK YOU
CARE I HOPE YOU CAN AND SEE ME-
SO THANK FOR INVITING ME TO
JOIN YOU ALL THIS MORNING- AND
FOR YOUR ON GOING PARTNERSHIP
DURING THIS EXTREMELY
CHALLENGING TIMES GOOD TO BE
HERE LAST DECEMBER I JOINED THE
NOOSE IN ADMINISTRATION AS
SENIOR ADVISER TO THE GOVERNOR
AND DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PARK OPENS AS YOU
AS YOU WELL KNOW IT- PRIOR TO
THAT I'VE BEEN WORKING AS A
VOLUNTEER. TO HELP THE GOVERNOR
AND TEAM ADDRESS THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS I STARTED MAY I
ONE THING LED TO ANOTHER AND I
SIGNED ON FULL TIME A FEW
MONTHS AGO SO IT'S A PRIVILEGE
FOR ME TO JOIN ALL OF YOU IN
SERVING THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA AS WE WORK TO
RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC AND
TO REBUILD OUR ECONOMY AND I
APPRECIATE. YOU HAVING ME HERE
TODAY- AS YOU ALL KNOW GO THIS
LEADS THE STATE'S JOB GROWTH
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
EFFORTS- WE OFFER A RANGE OF
SERVICES TO BUSINESS OWNERS- IN
ADDITION- YEAH GO BECAUSE
HOUSES THE OFFICE OF THE SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCATE- SBA ARE THAT
OPERATES WITHIN GO BIZ AND
SERVES AS THE VOICE OF SMALL
BUSINESS PROVIDING THEM WITH
ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS RESOURCES
AND ONGOING SUPPORT- AS YOU ALL
KNOW FIRST HAND CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS HAVE BEEN
HEAVILY IMPACTED BY THIS
PANDEMIC AND- MANY OF YOU HAVE.
ALSO COMMENTED ON THAT THIS
MORNING- INTO OUT ALL THAT I
THINK YOU SEEN FIRST HAND HOW
HARD THEY'VE WORKED TO SERVE
THEIR COMMUNITIES WHEN POSSIBLE
TO KEEP THEIR CUSTOMERS THEIR
PLACE SAFE ON TO PROVIDE A GOOD
ANSWER THAT WE ALL NEED AND
IT'S BEEN REALLY CHALLENGING-
SB. OF LAST YEAR WHICH SEEMS
LIKE A LIFETIME AGO EITHER MORE
THAN FOUR MILLION SMALL
BUSINESSES HERE IN CALIFORNIA
SO WHEN THE PANDEMIC HIT GOBIZ
AND THE TEAM THAT PRECEDED ME-
AND ESPECIALLY OFFICE OF SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCATE QUICKLY.
BEGAN TO DEVELOP RESOURCES TO
HELP SMALL BUSINESSES AND
BUSINESSES OF ALL SIZES BUT
THOSE INCLUDED TRAININGS CROSS
AGENCY ADVOCACY TECHNICAL
SYSTEMS AND TOOLS TO HELP
BUSINESSES TRANSITION. TO
ONLINE- TO REALLY HELP PROTECT
THE BUSINESSES THAT INCLUDE THE
SHOPS. SHOP SEAT SHOP LOCAL
CAMPAIGN. AND TO GET THE-
CAMPAIGN GET DIGITAL CALIFORNIA
CAMPAIGN SO BOTH OF AGAIN TO.
THERE'S A- HI DON'T YOU KNOW
RESOURCE TO TRAIN ON WITHOUT
POSSIBLE- IS ONE OF THE WAYS
THIS CAN HAS US TO SORT OF BE.
AND IN A AND TO DOUBLE DOWN ON
OUR APP TO DO. CONSTANTLY
CHANGING. AND ON GOING AND GROW
NEED TO OUR BUSINESS IS ACROSS
THE STATE. ALL RISKS TO THOSE
CHANGES TO BE THE FOUNDING. OF
GOVERNOR SMALL BUSINESS. IT'S A
MULTI PRO FINE RELIEF EFFORT TO
FIT WHAT BUSINESS NEED SIZE
GIVES. OVER THE LAST MONTHS-
THEY'RE GONNA NUMBER OF PRO ON
THAT- KILL READ FONG WHICH IS A
PRIVATE PARTNER. TO HELP SMALL
BUSINESSES IN UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITY. ACCESS LOW INTEREST
LOW AND I FREE AND SIR TO HELP
THEM ACCESS THOSE. OTHERS ALSO
BEEN TEN AND FEE RELIEF YOU
TALK ON A LITTLE TODAY- THE
MAIN STREET OF HIRING TAX
CREDIT WE AUTHOR A HUNDRED
DOLLAR. IN TAX CUTS FOR SMALL
TO HIRE REHIRE EMPLOYEES. AND
WE ELIMINATED THE EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR FRANCHISE TAX
FOR FIRST YEAR. AND YOU KNOW
EVEN IN THE MIDDLE OF. WE SAW
RAY. NUMBER OF NEW BUSINESS
STARTS I 20% INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER SMALL BUSINESSES IN MANY
WAYS AS A RESULT OF THAT. OUR
FEE RELIEF- THERE'S ALSO THE
COLD NINETEEN TENANT. ACT
THROUGH THE BUSINESS CONSUMERS
AND AGE. AND OF COURSE
CALIFORNIA'S BUSINESS CODE NINE
REALLY GRANT PROGRAM- WHICH IS
ONE OF THE ONE TIME TODAY- AS
YOU ALL KNOW GOVERNOR
PARTNERSHIP THE U. ANNOUNCED
THE CAL REALLY GRAB PROGRAM
LASSEN OF THIRTY. AND THEN THE
OFFICE SMALL BIZ ADVOCATE OPEN
THE GRANT PORTAL ON DECEMBER.
SO JUST A MONTHLY. WITH
COMMITTED TO HELPING AS AS BIZ
AS- ASK AS POSSIBLE THE RELEASE
THAT THIS WAS TO TRY AROUND
FAST AND GET MY INTO THE OF OUR
BUSINESSES. ALL I KNOW THAT
SEEN THE- DATA- OR MUCH OF IT
FROM BOTH AROUND OBVIOUSLY DO
THE- FIVE HUNDRED NINE DOLLARS
AND ROUND- AND- THEN TO PUT
TOGETHER RECEIVED. THAN THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
APPLE. FOR MORE THAN FOUR AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLAR IN GRANTS
ACROSS ALL. K. COUNTIES STYLE.
IN OTHER WORDS. THEY NEED OF
OUR SMALL OWNERS HAS WAY
OUTSTRIPPED FUNDS THEY- YOU
KNOW WHAT YOU YOU KNOW THANKED
ALL OF YOU WE- YOU PASSED
NEEDED OUT. BILL THAT INCREASES
FOR THAT PROGRAM FOR. ROUNDS OF
FOR FULL. FROM FIVE HUNDRED NO
DOLLARS MORE THAN. BILLION AND
THAT WILL PER. GREAT UP TO
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES. BY
PANDEMIC TAKE CARE OF SO MUCH
OF THE NEED THAT WE ARE SEEN-
WHERE THERE'S WONDERFUL
AVAILABLE TO ME BECAUSE ALL.
FIFTEEN DOLLARS AND WHICH YOU
KNOW. WE YOUR- THE NONPROFIT.
AND WHICH AND THEN ASSESS HARD-
THEY'RE NOT WILL SIGN BILL THIS.
IT'S POSSIBLE WE KNOW THEY'RE
HURTING WE SEEN IT WE HEAR
ABOUT IT I KNOW YOU HAVE ALL.
OF THAT ON THE FRONT LINES
WITH. THE BUSINESS OWNERS IN
YOUR COMMUNITIES- SO
SUPPLEMENTING THE EXISTING
FEDERALLY WILL BE KEY TO THEIR
SURVIVAL. AS YOU ALL KNOW-
SMALL BUSINESSES ARE THE
BACKBONE OF OUR ECONOMY. AT THE
HEART OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND AS
THEY OPEN THEIR DOORS AND THEY
HIRE EMPLOYEES AND HIGHER BACK
EMPLOYEES AND GET BACK TO WORK.
THAT WILL HELP ACCELERATE OUR
ECONOMIC RECOVERY SO NOT ONLY
WILL HELP THEM SURVIVE. YOU
KNOW PUT FUEL- INTO THE REST OF
THE ECONOMY- WE PROBABLY WON'T
BE ABLE TO REACH EVERYONE
BECAUSE THAT DEMAND CONTINUES
TO OUTSTRIP AVAILABLE FUNDS
WERE WORKING TO DO AS MUCH AS
WE CAN. TO FIND OTHER WAYS TO
BE HELPFUL. SO WITH THAT I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
INVITING ME TO JOIN THE
REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ALL GOING FORWARD AS
WE SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S
ENTREPRENEURS. AND THE
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE AND HELP
OUR STATE RECOVER IN WAYS THAT
ARE BOTH EQUITABLE AND
PROSPEROUS FOR ALL- SUPPOSED TO
TALK MORE ABOUT THE DETAILS OF
THE PROGRAM I LIKE TO
INTRODUCED. INTRODUCED MICHELLE
REDMOND- SHE IS THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF CAL ALWAYS BE A THE
ACTING DEPUTY DIRECTOR AND SHE
CAN PROVIDE MORE SPECIFICS ON
THE- OCTOBER NINETEEN WILL BE
GRANT PROGRAM SO AGAIN. MANY.
THANKS LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU ALL. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MY AT OUR FIRST ENOUGH OF
COURSE YOUR SEATS ADVISE. WHOSE
THE LINE. DO YOU HAVE A FEW
MOMENTS THAT YOU KNOW YOU CAN
TAKE. A MAYBE COMMITTEE MEMBER
MAY HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS
REGARDING THE SMALL BUSINESS
PRESS. BOB SURE ENOUGH I. A
ABSOLUTE IF I ANSWER THEM I'M
SURE MICHELLE CAN. PROVIDE MORE
DE. ABSOLUTE WON'T UNDER THAT
THIS PROGRAM IS YOU VERY UNIQUE
TO CALIFORNIA WHICH- THIS SITE
HAS NEVER BEEN. THIS AMOUNT OF
GRANTS NEVER BEEN PROVIDED I TO
BUSINESSES ANYWHERE NEAR THIS
MAGNITUDE AND SO APPROVING SUCH
A SIGNIFICANT APPROPRIATION. I
WE FACE THE MAJOR TASK OF
ENSURING. GRANTS ARE EQUITABLY
DISTRIBUTED. I DISBURSEMENT OF
THE FUNDS ARE TRANSPARENT. AND
THAT'S JUST PROGRAM MANAGEMENT
COURSES HELD ACCOUNTABLE. I DO
HAVE A QUESTION- DEALING WITH
JUST REALLY UNDERSTANDING THE
MARKET BASED ON THE PROGRAM'S
REVENUE LIMITS HOW MANY SMALL
BUSINESSES AND HOW MANY
NONPROFITS IN CALIFORNIA. MEETS
THE ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA AND
THE- CRITERIA. I DON'T KNOW THE
ANSWER TO- CHAIR I MIGHT THERE
ARE- I MEAN WE KNOW MANY PEOPLE
APPLY IN THE FOR TWO ROUNDS
RIGHT NOW WAS AS WE SAY- OF THE-
THERE ARE I'M SURE MORE WHO.
WHAT WILL APPLY AS WE REACH OUT
THROUGH OUR NETWORK OF SMALL
BUSINESS ASSISTANCE CENTERS AND
OTHER- PARTNERS UP THERE THERE
ARE MANY BUT I DON'T KNOW THAT
THEIR I DON'T KNOW THAT. AND
MICHELLE MAYBE YOU HAVE. AN
ANSWER I DON'T KNOW THAT WE
HAVE WE CAN QUANTIFY THE TOTAL
NUMBER BUSINESSES WHO WOULD
MEET THAT CRITERIA. AND THEN
JUST START ONE OF THE
YOUNGSTERS I'M SURE CHAU THEY
SPOKE TO. TOUCH ON THAT. I AM
HAPPY TO JUMP AND HE- UNTIL WE
KNOW THE NEARLY. SOME THAT SAYS
THIS IS A THE STATE OF. ARE
TWENTY EMPLOYEE- OR- AND SO
MOST OF THEM WOULD LIKE SAY-
INTO THE L. CRITERIA FOR THE
PROGRAM- BUT SMALL BUSINESSES.
AS YOU KNOW LIMITED SO. OFFICE
LEVEL. THANK YOU MICHELLE AND
JIM ONE ONE OTHER QUESTION I DO
HAVE ABOUT THE I TURN THE TO MY
COLLEAGUE ON THE COMMITTEE.
THIS MORNING AS- IT OVER WHAT'S
UNDERSTAND COMMON MINOR OWNER
WOMAN OWNED BUSINESSES APPLY
FOR THE GRANTS I KNOW THAT IT
IS STILL UNCLEAR WHETHER THE
PROGRAM IS MEETING ITS GOALS-
BUT WHY HAS INFORMATION ABOUT
WHO APPLIES NOT BEEN PUBLICLY
REPORTED BY RACE. ETHNICITY
GENDER AND INDUSTRY SECTORS YET.
MICHELLE DO YOU WANT TO TAKE
THAT WOULD. HI THANK YOU YES SO
WE ARE CURRENTLY IN THE
SELECTION PHASE RIGHT NOW AND
SO- ONCE WE ARE ABLE TO THE
APPLICANTS FROM SELECTED TWO
AWARDED WE WILL BE SHARING- THE
AGGREGATE INFORMATION ABOUT BE
AWARDED APPLICANTS. WONDERFUL
AND WE HAVE REALLY. YEAH NO
PROBLEM. LET ME TURN IT OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WARNER FORGOT. YES THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR. A COOPERATIVE WORK ON
THIS IMPORTANT PROGRAM- ONE OF
THE THINGS I THINK ALL
LEGISLATORS AND OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE VERY
INTERESTED IN IS ONE OF THE
CHECKS AND BALANCES THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO BE PLACING ON THIS
PROGRAM- TO INSURE. BEFORE
DISTRIBUTION DURING
DISTRIBUTION AFTER DISTRIBUTION
THAT THE GRANTS ARE GING TO
WHERE THEY NEED TO GO AND TO
REDUCE ANY IMP ANY POSSIBLE
FRAUD THAT CAN HAPPEN. SO WHAT
CHECKS AND BALANCES
TRANSPARENCY HOW OFTEN YOU
REPORT OUT ON WHO'S GETTING THE
GRANT HOW THEY'RE HELPING HOW
ARE YOU MEASURING SUCCESS AS
APPROACH. HI THIS IS MICHELLE
AGAIN IT'S- JUSTIN HERE TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION SO- IN
SELECTING THE INTERMEDIARY WE
WANTED TO ENSURE THAT THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT WAS IN PLACE-
WOULD IT PREVENT. ANY SORT OF
FRAUD WASTE AND ABUSE AND SO AT
THE DIRECTION OF THE STATE WE
ENSURE THAT- PROPERTY
DOCUMENTATION WOULD BE
COLLECTED BY THE APPLICANT- AS
WELL AS THE TECHNOLOGY ON THE
BACK AND- WOULD BE ABLE TO DO
BACKGROUND CHECKS. AND CREDIT
CHECKS AGAIN ON THE APPLE GET-
TO ENSURE THAT THERE ARE NO-
FRIDAY- BE OCCURRED- KERR IN
THE PROGRAM ITSELF I'M IN SO
THAT TECHNOLOGY IS IN PLACE-
AND AT. THE PROGRAM ITSELF WAS
SET UP TO BE A SIMPLE AND
EFFICIENT AS POSSIBLE AND SO WE
HAVE THOSE CONTROLS- BUILT IN-
TO THE PROGRAM. SORRY I DON'T
THINK I CLEAR THAT WHAT SORT OF
ALREADY ARE YOU GONNA BE DOING
WHILE THIS PROGRAM IS RUN
RUNNING OUT SO YOU HAVE.
PREVENTION ON THE FRONT END
YOUR VERIFICATION AND THE
APPLICATION PROCESS. BUT I
THINK IT WOULD BEHOOVE US AS-
AS THE STATE TO ENSURE THAT
WERE REGULARLY LOOKING AT THE
DISTRIBUTION- AND MAKING SURE
THAT ALL THOSE SAFEGUARDS WERE
PUT IN THE FRONT AND- ARE
ACTUALLY BEING DONE- THROUGHOUT
THE PROCESS AS THE GRANTS GO
OUT. SO I THINK IT WOULD BE
VERY WISE FOR US TO HAVE SOME
TRANSPARENCY ON WHO'S GETTING
THE GRANTS. HOW THEY'RE
HELPING. AND TO DO REGULAR
AUDITS- SO THAT WE DON'T END UP
IN OTHER SITUATIONS LIKE WE
HAVE WITH OUR STATE GOVERNMENT.
WHERE SOMETIMES. EVEN WITH ALL
GOOD INTENTIONS THINGS CAN GO
AWRY. THANK YOU AND IF I COULD
JUST HAVE A MOMENT- AND
WONDERFUL- JUST VERY BRIEFLY
HERE. LET ME TURN TO OUR WHILE
YOU DO THAT MICHELLE IF I COULD
JUST TURN TO. ONE OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WHO'S WITH US
VIRTUALLY WHO'D LIKE TO ASK A
QUESTION. ALL WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PARTY PETRIE-NORRIS HE
CONNECTED. YES THANK YOU SO
MUCH CHAIR CERVANTES AND I
THANK YOU- MYERS AND MISS MAC
RODMAN PERKS FOR JOINING US
THIS MORNING- I THAT LIKE OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBER WAS REALLY
PLEASE THAT WE WERE ABLE TO
PASS SB EIGHTY SEVEN YESTERDAY
WITH BIPARTISAN UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT AND DIED DELIVER.
MEANINGFUL RELIEF TO HELP
STABILIZE CALIFORNIA'S SMALL
BUSINESSES WHO ARE HURTING SAID
ESPECIALLY RIGHT NOW ON WITH
THE INITIAL ROUND AND A FUNDING
I THINK THERE WERE MANY
SUCCESSES AND MANY THINGS THAT
WE CAN'T AND SHOULDN'T
CELEBRATE IN ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE CERTAINLY IDENTIFIED AS
AN OPPORTUNITY I BELIEVE
STATEWIDE WAYS I NEED TO
ENHANCE OUR OUTREACH AND
COMMUNICATION EFFORTS AND I TO
DO AN EVEN BETTER JOB. ENGAGING
OUR STATEWIDE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PARTNERS CAN YOU
SPEAK BRIEFLY TO ISSUE OUT WHAT
YOU ARE DOING AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS ADDITIONAL
TWO POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS
IN GRANT FUNDING WHAT ARE YOU
DOING TO ENHANCE THAT OUTREACH
AND COMMUNICATION AND ENSURE
THAT ARE PARTICULARLY OUR MOST
UNDERSERVED BUSINESSES ARE ABLE
TO- PARTICIPATE AND. TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS PROGRAM.
ABSOLUTELY AND MATTER CHAIR BE.
FOR TO PROVIDE MY PRETTY SHE- I
THINK IT CAN HELP LOWER YOUR A
LOT DISK. THAT ARE BEING
PROPOSED AT THIS. YEAH SIR IF
WE THE ABILITY TO DO THAT WE
CAN DO SO. GREAT THANK YOU. AND
SO RECOGNIZING THE ENORMOUS
IMPACTS SMALL THIS AVE EASTER
OPEN- OUR OFFICE CARILLO BA THE
OFFICES THE SMOKERS ABBOTT HAS
BEEN TRY FOR RESERVE AS WELL AS
BEST PRACTICES ARE THIS AND
LOCAL AND PRIVATE GRANT
PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESSES OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL MONTHS AND SO WE KNEW
THAT IN ORDER TO REACH THE
SMALL BUSINESSES ESPECIALLY
THOSE MOST HARD HIT BY THE
NINETEEN THE PANDEMIC. THE
REGIONAL STAFF HOME ORDERS AND
THE CLERK BLUEPRINT FOR SAFER
KANEMI- WE HAD TO CREATE A
DISTRIBUTION MODEL THROUGH A
STRONG NETWORK OR PLATFORM THAT
HAD SUCCESS IN REACHING IN
PROVIDING ASSISTANCE TO
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE
AND THAT THE SPECIALLY TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES WHO HISTORICALLY
FACE BARRIERS IN ACCESSING
CAPITAL AND HAVE EXPERIENCED
HIGH IMPACT FROM THE PANDEMIC.
UP IN OUR OFFICE WE WANTED TO
SERVICE MANY SMALL BUSINESSES
AS POSSIBLE AND IS IT EQUITABLE
MANNER AS POSSIBLE WITH THE
GOAL OF REACHING THOSE THAT
AGAIN WHAT MOST NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED I'M. IN A COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROCESS. AND SO BAY ON
OUR EARLY- THE GOVERNOR OFFICE
AND THE LINE. WE OUTLINED AND
GRANT PROGRAM THAT WOULD FOCUS
HELPING ON GETTING CASH RELIEF
INTO THE HANDS OF A LARGE CROSS
SECTION OF BUSINESSES AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE I'M IN SO.
THAT THAT ALLOW THE PROGRAM-
FOR IT TO BE A STRUCTURED AS
SIMPLE AS POSSIBLE FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES WHILE IMPLEMENTING
THE CONTROLS AS MENTIONED FOR
FRAUD WASTE AND ABUSE- I'M THE
PROGRAM WOULD BE SCALABLE AND
AFFORDABLE WITH MINIMAL
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. BUT STILL
LEVERAGE THE EXISTING
ECOSYSTEMS FOR OUTREACH AND
SENSE TOO MANY OTHER PROGRAMS-
THAT WERE PART OF A RESEARCH
AND- THAT WE LOOK TO WORK FIRST
COME FIRST SERVE. OR SHUT DOWN
TOO EARLY WHEN DEMAND PEAKS IT
WAS DECIDED VERY EARLY ON BUT
THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM WOULD
NOT BE A FIRST COME FIRST SERVE
PROGRAM I'M IN OTHER WORDS
OPERATE ON A ROLLING BASIS AND
INSTEAD WOULD BE OPEN TO ALL
ELIGIBLE BUSINESSES. UNTIL THE
VERY END OF THE CLOSE OF THE
ROUNDS AND THEN PRIORITIZE
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN MOST
IMPACTED BY KOBE NINETEEN I'M
AGAIN AS DEMONSTRATED BY THEIR
GEOGRAPHY. INDUSTRY AND IMPACT
AS A RESULT. OF ACCESS TO OTHER
SUPPORT. AND SO TO THAT ARE ALL-
WE TO FISH TO DEVELOP MARK.
WITH THE RE THAT WAS DONE. AND
INSTEAD BEST. WE WORKED WITH
THE GOBIZ BUSINESS. UNIT TO.
INTERPOSED IN X. THAT EMERGES
KERR FOR INTERMEDIARY TO
SUPPORT THE PROGRAM- YOU KNOW
WE FOR GUIDE AND PUBLIC POSTING
THE- P. HONESTY COUNTY PARTS
WEB FOR EIGHTEEN. WHICH
INCLUDED ALLOW FOR DAY PERIOD
FOR PUBLIC. ANSWERED ARE ALL
SCHOOL EACH. APPLE THAT WAS
SENT IT AND IN SEVEN TEN TO WAS
PUBLIC POST FOR DAYS. AND THEN
AFTER AFTER THE CALL WAS. ADULT
ARE PRIORITIZE WORKING WITH THE
INTERVIEW WITH PRIOR IT IN.
USING IN A MINUTE LARGE SCALE
GRANT INDOOR LONG PROGRAM AT
ESPECIALLY TO THE ANDERSON
BUSINESS GROUPS I HAVE HAD
AGAIN AS HIS BARRIERS TO ACCESS
CAN. RE AND OUR- TO ENJOY THAT
THE INTERVIEW IS THAT WAS HAD
BE A TO SCALE ONE. QUICKLY TO
MEET THE PROGRAM'S WITH
TECHNOLOGY AND SYSTEMS TO
HANDLE THE DEMAND- THIS WAS
ESPECIALLY CRITICAL GIVEN THE
FUNDS HAD TO BE DISBURSED BY
THIS APRIL FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND SO GIVEN THIS TIME
FRAME THE INTERMEDIARY HAD TO
DEMONSTRATE THE ABILITY TO
OPERATE QUICKLY AND
EFFICIENTLY. WITH CONTROLS IN
PLACE AGAIN TO PREVENT THAT
FRAUD WASTE AND ABUSE THESE
CONTROLS- AS I HAD MENTIONED
EARLIER INCLUDE SCREENING FOR
REQUIRED DOCUMENTATION AS
DIRECTED BY THE STATE AND THEN
CONDUCTING. CREDIT CHECKS AND
BACKGROUND CHECKS. AND ENEMY-
HAD TO DEMAND THAT THEY IN THE-
STRONG NETWORK AND SEE. IS%
THOSE CAN TO I AND OTHER SMALL
BUSINESS ECOSYSTEM
ORGANIZATIONS TO QUICKLY ENGAGE
OUTREACH IN SUPPORT OF THE
SMALL BUSINESS COMMUNITIES. THE
CDFI IS ARE IN THE COMMUNITIES
OUT THERE MISSION BASED LENDERS
WORKING WITH UNDER SERVED- WITH
THAT AND BANKED AND UNDER
BANKED COMMUNITIES ALREADY. AND
SO IN ADDITION ARE ARE HE MADE
IT A PRIORITY FOR THE
INTERMEDIARY PARTNER AND
COLLABORATE WITH THE STATE'S
NETWORK OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS LIKE THE SMALL
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT CENTERS
AND WOMEN'S BUSINESS CENTERS
I'M BETTER HUNDRED PART BY THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE EXPANSION
PROGRAM. THAT OUR OFFICE
ADMINISTERS I'M IN THIS IS TO
EXPAND THE REGION SERVICES TO
UNDERSERVED SMALL BUSINESS
GROUPS WHO AGAIN WHO HAVE
HISTORICALLY FACED THOSE
BARRIERS TO RESOURCES CAPITAL
NETWORKS. AND SO WITH THAT YOU
KNOW WE ARE VERY PLEASED TO
REPORT THAT TO DATE THE
PARTNERS HAVE CONDUCTED OVER A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY ONE IN OURS
AND THAT'S REACHING OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND SMALL
BUSINESSES IN OVER EIGHTY
LANGUAGES. AND THAT BEGAN ON
DECEMBER TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT WHICH WAS ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE PROGRAM
WAS FIRST LAUNCHED- OUR OFFICE
IN THE INTERMEDIARY
CONTINUOUSLY ADDED. PARTNERS TO
THE PROGRAM. WHO THEN WORK WITH
THEIR LOCAL AND REGION PARTNER.
INCLUDING LOCAL AND ETHNIC
CHAMBER TO CREATE FOR REACH OF
THOSE. THE RELIEF GRANT
PROGRAM- HAS REALLY A LOT
QUICKLY TO A DE IS TO ADAPT TO
IT AND- AND I COULD MODIFY AND-
MORE CLARITY TO THE PLOT. I'M
INCREASING TECHNOLOGY CAPACITY
TO MANAGE THAT INCREDIBLE LARGE
DEMAND THAT WE SEE. I'M AND NOT
EXAM OF THIS IS THAT WHILE
THERE ARE CURRENTLY EIGHTEEN
LANGUAGES ON THE PLATFORM IN A
TOTAL THIRTY LANGUAGES SPOKEN
ACROSS OUR NETWORKS AND
WEBINARS IN DIFFERENT LANGUAGES
EVERY SINGLE DAY. THE
INTERMEDIARY MOVED TO TRANSLATE
THE APPLICATION INTO FIVE
DIFFERENT LANGUAGES FOR
PARTNERS TO USE WHEN GUIDING
SMALL BUSINESSES THROUGH THE
PROCESS. IT'S REALLY A HUB AND
SPOKE MODEL- IT WITH PRIMARY
PARTNERS IN A BROADER NETWORK A
LOCAL PROVIDERS IMPLYING THE
MESSAGE IN THE COMMUNITY- YOU
KNOW IN ADDITION. OUR OFFICE AN
INTERMEDIARY AND OUR PARTNERS
ARE GENERATING EARNED MEDIA AND
SOCIAL MEDIA. FOR EXAMPLE WE
HAVE LOCAL. TELAVI NETWORKS
LIKE YOU KNOW. AMPLIFY THE PRO.
AND WE HAD A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER ACTUALLY- SHE SPOKE TO US
AND LEARN THAT ABOUT THE
PROGRAM FROM WATCHING UNIVISION
AND ROBLIN AND DESPITE BEING
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT AND
I'M CONNECTED TO ANY OF THE
PARTNERS- SHE WAS ABLE TO
APPLY. TO THE PROGRAM AND IN
FACT THE MAJORITY OF APPLICANTS
COME STRAIGHT THROUGH THE
WEBSITE AND THAT'S CALIFORNIA
C. A. RELIEF GRANT DOT COM AND
WE CONNECT THEM TO THE GRANTS
AND THE PARTNERS ON FROM THERE.
SO WHILE THE PROGRAM IS NOT
MEANT TO SOLVE ALL THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE AN
ENTREPRENEURIAL IN OUR SMALL
BUSINESS ECOSYSTEM- WE'RE STILL
VERY PLEASED WITH THE OUTCOMES
WHICH HAVE INCLUDED CONNECTING
THEM TO CVS BUYS. IN THE
TECHNICAL SYSTEMS PROVIDERS
WITH SMALL BUSINESSES WHO NEED
THAT ONGOING SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AND JUST TO IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME HERE I DO WANT TO MAKE
SURE IF THERE'S A AN ADDITIONAL
QUESTION ONE LAST QUESTION FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS RELATING. TO
THIS. ISSUE SENIOR. NINE WELL
AGAIN YOU KNOW THE YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING THIS IS MORNING-
YOURSELF IN A DIRECT MEYER I
WILL BE SURE TO YOU KNOW THE
STATE- CLOSED AS WE CONTINUE TO
WORK TOGETHER TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF OUR SMALL BUSINESS AND
NONPROFIT COMMUNITIES BUT-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU. LET ME GO AHEAD AND
CONTINUE ON WITH THEIR NEXT
ITEM OF BUSINESS- WHICH IS
MOVING BACK TO AGENDA ITEM TO.
LET ME INTRODUCE OUR FOR NEXT
WEEK OR COULD GET READY LET ME
INTRODUCE OUR NEXT SPEAKER WITH
US THIS MORNING IS DR ROBERT
FAIRLY. WHO IS A PROFESSOR OF
ECONOMICS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SANTA CRUZ SINCE THE
BIG PANDEMIC BEGAN HE HAS BEEN
TRACKING ITS IMPACT ON SMALL
BUSINESSES AND SHARING HIS
RESEARCH WITH POLICYMAKERS
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES AND
HIS FIRST REPORT HE REVEALS
THAT WHILE MOST MAJOR
INDUSTRIES IN THE U. S. BASE
LARGE DROPS IN THE NUMBER OF
BUSINESS OWNERS. IN THE EARLY
MONTHS OF THE PANDEMIC
BUSINESSES OWNED BY PEOPLE OF
COLOR WERE HARDEST HIT USING
ASSIMILATION MODEL DOCTOR
FAIRLY ESTIMATED THAT BETWEEN
FEBRUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY AND
APRIL TWENTY TWENTY THERE WAS A
DECREASE OF 41% AMONG BLACK
OWNED BUSINESSES. 32% A MONTH
BY NEXT OWN BUSINESSES AND 26%
AMONG ASIAN OWNED BUSINESSES
FROM THIS BASE RESEARCH SHE HAS
PUBLISHED SEVERAL OF THE
REPORT'S TRACING THE IMPACT OF
THE PANDEMIC. TODAY HE WILL NOT
ONLY BE DISCUSSING THAT
RESEARCH BUT HE WILL ALSO BE
SHARING I CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC
INFORMATION A DOCTOR FAIRLY
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US THIS
MORNING I PLEASE BEGAN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU SO I
WANT TO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR INVITING ME FOR THIS
HEARING OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. SO I HAVE A POWER
POINT PRESENTATION THAT IS NOT
I CANNOT SHARE SCREEN SO I
THINK SOMEONE IS GOING TO SET
IT UP FOR ME. YES WE'RE
HANDLING NOT RIGHT NOW. GREAT
OKAY SO NEXT SLIDE. SO I'M A
PROFESSOR OF ECONOMICS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SANTA
CRUZ I'VE BEEN DOING RESEARCH
ON ENTREPRENEURSHIP RACIAL
INEQUALITY IN SMALL BUSINESS
POLICY FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS NOW I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
DISCUSS THE FINDINGS FROM MY
RESEARCH ON THE IMPACTS OF THE
PANDEMIC ON SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS. ONE THING THAT'S BEEN
REALLY DIFFICULT IS FINDING UP
TO DATE INFORMATION AS YOU KNOW
SOME OF THE SPEAKERS ALREADY
MENTIONED IT'S EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT TO GET THIS KIND OF
INFORMATION AND SO ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I'VE BEEN DOING
THIS OVER THE PAST NINE MONTHS
PRETTY MUCH SINCE THE PANDEMIC
STARTED. I'VE BEEN ANALYZING
THAT DATA COMPILING IT YOU KNOW
LOOKING FOR DIFFERENT SOURCES
THAT I CAN FIND AND SO I'VE
BEEN DOING A LOT OF WORK MOSTLY
ON THE NATION AS A WHOLE BUT
I'VE ALSO BEEN CALCULATING
ESTIMATES FOR CALIFORNIANS SO
THIS HEARING BUT I DID WAS I
FOUND THAT SOME OF THE MOST
RECENT DATA IT JUST BECAME
AVAILABLE. SO PART OF THAT IS
GOING TO BE FOR JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SO THIS WILL BE THE
FIRST TIME I PEOPLE PRESENTED
THESE NUMBERS AND THEN ALSO
SOME OF THE REVENUE DATA THAT
I'M STUDYING FOR CALIFORNIA FOR
THE THIRD QUARTER OF TWENTY
TWENTY JUST BECAME AVAILABLE SO
I'M GONNA SHOW YOU SOME OF
THOSE NUMBERS IN THE SECOND. SO
NEXT LINE. SO I'M FOCUSED ON
THREE DIFFERENT RESEARCH
QUESTIONS OVERALL FOR THE
PANDEMIC. SO THE BIG ONE IS
WHAT HAPPENED A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS. INDEPENDENT
DISPROPORTIONATELY CLOSE
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES IS A
KEY QUESTIONS NOT. THEN ANOTHER
QUESTION I'VE BEEN INTERESTED
IN. IS HOW MUCH TOO SMALL
BUSINESSES LOSE AND SALES
DURING THE EARLY STAGES OF A
PANDEMIC. WHAT TYPES OF
BUSINESSES WERE HIT HARD OR THE
WHAT WE THINK- HAS HAPPENED OR
ARE THERE OTHER INDUSTRIES OR
TYPES OF BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
BEEN AND HEARTS. AND I'VE ALSO
BEEN REALLY INTERESTED IN
STUDYING THE GOVERNMENT RELIEF
PROGRAMS. SO I FOCUSED ON THE
U. S. ONES THAT PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAMS. IN THE I
DON'T PROGRAMS. AND THE BIG
QUESTION THERE IS THAT I'M
INTERESTED IN IS WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'VE BEEN DISTRIBUTED EVENLY
TO MINORITY COMMUNITIES ALL
TALK ABOUT THAT. YOU KNOW SOME
OF MY RESEARCH A- TO YOU. NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. SO THE TIMING OF
THE PAN. HI THIS IS PRETTY WELL
KNOWN RIGHT MARCH A LOT THE WAY
HEALTH OR TO CLEAR NINETY
ATTENDED SAN FRANCISCO AREA
PRETTY MUCH THE FOR PLACE TO
MAKE AND CHAU IN PLACE RESTRICT.
MARCH THE STATE BECAUSE IMPOSES
RISK MARCH AT NEW YORK STATE
AND THEN BY EARLY MOST IMPOSE
SOCIAL DISTANCING. THIS IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WHAT I'M
GONNA DO IS COMPARE EVERYTHING
FROM FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY
SKIP OVER MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
AND THEN THEN GO TO APRIL
TWENTY TWENTY SO NEXT SLIDE
PLEASE. SO IF YOU LOOK AT THE
NUMBER OF ACTIVE BUSINESS
OWNERS IN THE U. S. CD'S ARE
OWNERS. THEY HAVE SOME KIND OF
WORK ETHIC IN THEIR BUSINESS SO
I CANNOT LOOK AT THEIR SALES
HERE I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU THAT
A SECOND ANOTHER PROJECT. BUT
HERE I'M JUST LOOKING AT
WHETHER OR NOT THE BUSINESS
OWNER IS CURRENTLY ACTIVE. IT'S
ACTUALLY RELATIVELY STEADY THIS
IS FOR THE NATION AS A WHOLE
IT'S RELATIVELY STEADY OVER
TIME. BUT WHAT YOU SEE IS THIS
UNPRECEDENTED LEVEL OF THE DROP
IN APRIL TWENTY TWENTY. IF YOU
COMPARE THIS TO THE GREAT
RECESSION. IN THAT ONE MONTH.
OF APRIL WE LOST TWENTY OVER
20% OF ACTIVE BUSINESS OWNERS
OVER THE ENTIRE GREAT RECESSION
WE ONLY LOST FIVE PERCENT. NEXT
LIGHT. THERE WERE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACTS ON
MINORITY GROUPS SO AFRICAN
AMERICANS WE SAW A LOSS OF
FORTY ONE PERCENT. LAST NEXT
32% AND ASIAN. BUSINESS OWNERS
26% SO THOSE NUMBERS WE JUST
MENTIONED CEMEX FIGHT. NOW WHAT
I'VE BEEN INTERESTED IN SINCE
THAT KIND OF EARLY BROWN OF
CLOSURES HAS THERE BEEN A
REBOUND TO SOME OF THOSE
BUSINESSES ONLY TEMPORARILY
CLOSED AND REOPEN. EXIDE I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN A STEADY
IMPROVEMENT IN ACTIVE BUSINESS
OWNERSHIP EVERY SINGLE MONTH UP
UNTIL OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY K.
PLEASE NEXT FIVE. THAT GROWTH
HAS BEEN PRETTY MUCH COVERED BY
DIFFERENT GROUPS IN THE
POPULATION SEATED ON THE FAR
LEFT HERE YOU CAN SEE- THE
NUMBERS FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS
THE MIDDLE ONE IS FOR LATIN.
AND THE THIRD- SET UP
GROCERIES- CENTER CALLS IS FOR
ASIAN AMERICANS SO FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND LATIN ACTS BUT WE
SEEN AS KIND OF A STEADY
INCLINE. BUSINESS OPENINGS.
ASIAN AMERICANS THERE IS BEEN A
DIFFERENT STORY WE CAN TALK
ABOUT THAT LITTLE BIT MORE
MEDIAN THE QUESTION AND ANSWER
BUT FOR THE MOST PART IT'S
RELATIVELY AND KNOWING WHAT
HAPPENED THERE WHY IT STALLED
OUT. OKAY NEXT LINE. WHAT IS
HAPPENED SINCE OCTOBER IS. IS
CONCERNING. THERE HAS BEEN A
DROP IN BUSINESS ACTIVITY IT
HAPPENED NOVEMBER IT HAPPENED
IN SEPTEMBER AND IT HAPPENED
AGAIN IN THIS LATEST STATED BUT
AS I MENTIONED JUST BECAME
AVAILABLE A FEW DAYS AGO. AND I
PREPARED. FOR THIS HEARING. SO
WHAT YOU SEE IS THE STEADY
MONTH TO MONTH TO MONTH DECLINE
OVER THE LAST THREE MONTHS
SINCE OCTOBER. THE NEXT SLIDE.
WHAT HAPPENED IN CALIFORNIA SO
I GENERATE NEED ESTIMATES FOR
CALIFORNIA. FOR THIS HEARING SO
NEXT SLIDE. YOU CAN SEE IS
EXACTLY THE SAME PATTERN. RIGHT
WE SEE THIS KIND OF RELATIVELY
STEADY BUSINESS OWNERSHIP
ACTIVITY IN CALIFORNIA OVER YOU
KNOW THE PREVIOUS YEAR AND A
HALF OR SO THE BIG DROP IN
APRIL FROM FEBRUARY IN A MONTH
BY MONTH. INCLINE IN RATES
UNTIL OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY AND
THEN A REVERSAL RIGHT SO
CALIFORNIA IS ESSENTIALLY
FOLLOWING EXACTLY THE SAME
PATTERN AS THE U. S. OVERALL HE
NEXT LINE. SO THAT WOULD BE
REALLY INTERESTING TO COMPARE
THIS DIRECTLY RIGHT SO WE SEE
THE SAME PATTERN IN CALIFORNIA
IS THE LAST. BUT HOW. DIFFERENT
ARE THEY THE CHANGES OVER TIME
SO THE GOLD BARS HERE SHOW
CALIFORNIA THE BLUE BARS SHOW
UNITED STATES AND WHEN YOU CAN
SEE IS EARLY OFTEN THE PANDEMIC
SO IN APRIL MAY JUNE CALIFORNIA
WAS ACTUALLY HIT HARDER RIGHT
SO THE SHUTDOWNS WERE MORE
SEVERE IN CALIFORNIA. WHAT
HAPPENED IS- IN OCTOBER
NOVEMBER THEY WERE RELATIVELY
SIMILAR BUT THEN WHAT YOU SEE
IS IN DECEMBER JANUARY OR SEEN
KIND OF THE SAME TYPES OF
CLOSURES. AND SO REALLY WHAT'S
HAPPENED IS KIND OF THIS KIND
OF MORE RECENT RAMPART
SHUTDOWNS IS BEEN ROUGHLY THE
SAME AS CAL IN CALIFORNIA AND
THE WEST- CALIFORNIA SEEING A
10% DROP INSTEAD OF A 6% DROP.
BUT THE OTHER MONTHS- WERE
PRETTY SIMILAR. NEXT SLIDE.
YEAH DOES THIS LOOK BY I IN
RACIAL. SO IN CALIFORNIA THE
SAMPLE SIZES ARE TOO SMALL FROM
THE DATA THAT I'M USING TO
REPORT AFRICAN AMERICAN NUMBERS
BUT YOU CAN SEE THAT THERE'S- A
SIMILAR PATTERN FOR LATIN ACTS
AS OVERALL CALIFORNIA. THAT
THERE WAS A BIG DECLINE IN
APRIL AND THEN THERE WAS KIND
OF THIS MONTH BY MONTH REBOUND.
AND THEN KIND OF A STEADY WELL
YOU KNOW KIND OF PLATEAU AREA
AND THEN A LITTLE BIT OF A
SLIGHT DECLINE IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS. ASIAN
AMERICANS YOU CAN SEE THERE'S
MORE OF A KIND OF A STUBBORN
RECOVERY THERE. THAT IS A
MENTION BEFORE IS NOT ENTIRELY
CLEAR IT APPEARS AS THOUGH IT'S
PARTLY DUE TO TYPES OF
INDUSTRIES AND BUSINESSES.
ASIAN AMERICANS ON- MANY OF
THEM ARE IN KIND OF MORE PERSON
TO PERSON CONTACT TYPE
BUSINESSES. AND YOU CAN SEE
FINALLY FOR. WHITE NONLIFE
BACKS ON BUSINESSES CEMEX.
FIGHT NOW I'VE ALSO BEEN DOING.
ON LOS IN CAL. IT'S A-
DIFFICULT TO GET KIND OF. I'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION TO LOOK
AT AVERAGE SALES LOSSES. ALMOST
ALL OF MY RESEARCH IS FOCUSED
ON THE SECOND QUARTER OF TWENTY
TWENTY. NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
WHICH IS A VERY IMPORTANT
QUARTER BECAUSE THAT INCLUDES
APRIL MAY JUNE SO YOU CAN SEE
HERE IS TAXABLE SALES GROWTH
OVERALL GROWS ABOUT 325% EVERY
QUARTER AND THIS IS YOUR OVER
YOUR GROWTH SO WHAT YOU SEE
THAT IN THE FIRST QUARTER THERE
WAS A BIT OF A DECLINE. IN THE
SECOND QUARTER OF TWENTY TWENTY
WAS WHEN WE SAW HUGE DECLINES
OR LOOKING AT IT A DROP IN
TOTAL SALES OF BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA FIFTEEN PERCENT-
IT'S VERY INTERESTING IS THAT
IN THE THIRD QUARTER WE SEE A
REAL BIG CHUNK BACK NOT ALL THE
WAY BACK TO WHERE IT SHOULD BE
ABOUT 325% GROWTH RANGE BUT ALL
THE WAY BACK TO ESSENTIALLY
ZERO GROWTH SO WE WERE NOT SEEN
LOSSES THEN. THIS IS OF COURSE
COMPARED TO THE THIRD QUARTER
OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN SO I'M
NOT COMPARING THIS TO THE
PREVIOUS QUARTER WHICH I THINK
WAS THE KIND OF A BIG MISTAKE
WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT. GDP
NUMBERS FOR THE U. S. NEXT
SLIDE PLEASE. NOW HOW DID THIS
HIT DIFFERENT TYPES OF
BUSINESSES YOU CAN SEE THE ONES
THAT WE REALLY EXPECTED TO BE
HIT HARD ACCOMMODATION IS THE
ONE IN BLUE IN THE FAR LAST.
REAL NICE AND 90% DROP IN SALES
IN THE SECOND QUARTER OF TWENTY
TWENTY SO WAS JUST DEVASTATED
AND BACKORDERS DRINKING PLACES
ALCOHOLIC ARE YOU KNOW CARS.
THAT WAS HIT EXTREMELY HARD.
YOU CAN SEE ARTS ENTERTAINMENT
RACKS FULL SERVICE RESTAURANTS
WERE HIT HARD HIT STORES
CLOTHING STORES ALL THE ONES
THAT WE CAN EXPECT BUT THE
LOSSES WERE PRETTY SEVERE RIGHT
WE'RE SEEING LOSSES A FIFTY.
DOLLAR ALL THE WAY UP TO NINETY
PERCENT. ON THE FLIP SIDE A LOT
OF INDUSTRIES THAT DID FINE
THEY ACTUALLY CONTINUE TO GROW.
AND WANTED REALLY STICKS OUT IS
NON STORE RETAILERS WHICH
INCLUDES ONLINE. AND THAT GROUP
BY A HUNDRED EIGHTY PERCENT.
OVER COURT IN QUARTER TWO OF.
TWENTY POINT NEXT SLIDE PLEASE.
IN THE RESEARCH PROJECT THAT
WERE ON IT ALL LOOKS REALLY AND-
IN HOW THIS RELATED TO. THE
NUMBER OF KOBE CASES ANY COPING
CASES PER CAPITA EARLY ON. SO
THESE ARE BACK IN APRIL AND
MAY. AND WHAT I FOUND IS THAT
THERE SEEM TO BE A NEGATIVE
RELATIONSHIP SO REMARKABLY
CASES THAT WERE BEING RECORDED
PER CAPITA. IT LOOKS LIKE
CONSUMERS WORK AND I'M MORE
NERVOUS ABOUT GOING TO STORES
AND SHOPPING AT THE STORES. OUT
IT ALSO COULD BE RELATED TO
KIND OF MORE ENFORCEMENT OF
CLOSURES BUT THIS TIME THERE
WASN'T THAT KIND OF COUNTY BY
TIMELY CLOSURES THAT WE SEE NOW.
NEXT SLIDE. I'VE ALSO BEEN VERY
INTERESTED AS I MENTIONED IN
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AID THE PPP
AND I DON'T PROGRAMS IN THE
CARRIAGE ACT THE ROUTE TO
PRIORITIZE SERVING UNDERSERVED
MARKETS AND BUSINESSES ON BY
SOCIALLY AND ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED INDIVIDUALS SO
THE QUESTION I WAS INTERESTED
IN PEACE LONG PROGRAMS COACH
MINORITY COMMUNITIES SO I WAS
ABLE TO GET DATA FROM FIFTY
MILLION DIFFERENT LOANS TO
ANALYZE THIS REALLY CAREFULLY
CEMEX SLIDE PLEASE. AND WHAT I
FOUND IS THAT IF YOU LOOK AT
THE FIRST ROUND OF DPT PROGRAM
THERE ACTUALLY IS A VERY STRONG
NEGATIVE RELATIONSHIP WITH A
MINORITY SHARE THE COMMUNITY.
SO THOSE FUNDS DID NOT FLOW TO
MINORITY COMMUNITIES EARLY IN
THE FIRST ROUND WHAT HAPPENED.
IS CONGRESS REALIZE THIS AND
THEN SWITCH THE PROGRAM TO
REALLY GO OUT AND BE MUCH MORE
AGGRESSIVE ABOUT GETTING LOCAL
COMMUNITY BACK BANKS. FINANCIAL
TECH. INSTITUTIONS AND OTHER
TYPES OF LENDING AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS THAT COULD TARGET
LOW INCOME MINORITY AREAS AND
WHAT WE FOUND IS IN THE SECOND
ROUND IT DID REVERSE AND THAT
MINORITY- COMMUNITIES TO GET
LOANS. CAN BACKSIDE. SO WHAT
CAN WE DO TO ME FORWARD I THINK
THEY'RE SORT OF FOR TAKEAWAYS
FROM THE RESEARCH THAT I'VE
DONE IN THE PRESENTATION THAT
I'VE GIVEN. YES I THINK THERE
ARE THE NUMBER ONE PRIORITY IS
CONSUMERS NEED TO FEEL SAFE
AGAIN. WE NEED TO GET THE
VACCINE OUT WE NEED TO GET OUT
FASTER IN MY OPINION. YOU KNOW
PEOPLE ARE ANXIOUS TO GO BACK
TO RESTAURANTS AND SHOPS AND
DAKOTA DOWNTOWNS AND SHOP
LOCALLY BUT THEY ARE GOING TO
BE RELUCTANT TO DO THAT POLICE
YOU'LL SIX. I ONE IS MEAN NEED
MORE. ASSISTANCE I THINK THIS
IS A CRITICAL PERIOD FOR A LOT
OF SMALL BUSINESSES. I THINK
RENT RELIEF IS REALLY IMPORTANT
SO IT'S GREAT TO HEAR THAT THAT
BILL. PASSED YESTERDAY IN THE
GOVERNOR IS LIKELY TO SIGN IT
TODAY. WE ALSO NEED TO SLOW
ONLINE SHOPPING WHICH IS
HAPPENED PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC.
SMALL BUSINESSES NEED TO HAVE
MORE OF AN ONLINE PRESENCE SO
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT COULD
HELP IS. WHEN YOU LOOK AT A LOT
OF- ONLINE SEARCHES SEARCH
ENGINES. THEY OFTEN WILL SHOW
KIND OF BIG BOX STORES ARE
LARGER RETAILERS WOULD BE GREAT
IF THEY COULD FOCUS ON SMALL
BUSINESSES AND LOCAL BUSINESSES
SO THAT. YOU KNOW INDIVIDUALS
CAN PRIORITIZE THEM. I MEAN I
THINK MORE DATA ON RACE NEEDS
TO BE COLLECTED THAT IS CLEAR.
D. P. PT LOAN. PROGRAM WAS
CRITICIZED HEAVILY FOR NOT
COLLECTING THIS INFORMATION THE
RESEARCH THAT I SHOWED YOU JUST
LOOK AT THE MINORITY SHARE THE
COMMUNITY AND NOT. ACTUAL LOAN
RECIPIENTS I THINK THAT WAS A
HUGE MISTAKE THAT WAS MADE. AND
ALSO THIS WAS ACTUALLY
MENTIONED EARLIER IN IN THIS IN
THIS- SESSION. IS A COLLECTION
INFORMATION APPLICATIONS.
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT IS
WHO'S APPLYING FOR THESE LOANS
AND WHO'S GETTING DENIED FOR
THESE LOANS. IS. THERE RACIAL
EQUITY. IN THAT. BACKSIDE
PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THE
FINDINGS MY RESEARCH I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING YOUR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU FOR OUR CHAPTER I
DISCOVERED QUICKLY DO YOU KNOW
WHAT DO YOU HOPE FOR A POLICY
LEADERS CAN TAKE AWAY FROM YOUR
RESEARCH AND- WHAT OTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS AS TO PERHAPS
ACTIONS THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CAN TAKE TO MITIGATE THE
DISPARITIES AMONG. DIFFERENT
BUSINESS OWNER GROUPS. YEAH I
MEAN I THINK THE ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU KNOW WE FIRST
NEED THAT KIND OF INFORMATION
RIGHT IF WE HAD BETTER RECENT
FORMATION ON APPLICATIONS. BUT
A RECENT FORMATION A LOAN
RECIPIENTS I THINK WE COULD
START TO LOOK AT THIS EXTREMELY
CAREFULLY. RIGHT NOW I FEEL
LIKE CHARLIE MY HANDS AND OTHER
RESEARCHERS ANSWER TIGHT WE
IT'S SO HARD TO GET THE DATA TO
BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND. EXACTLY
WHAT'S GOING ON SOME OF THE
THEORIES ARE THERE IT'S A LACK
OF INFORMATION ANOTHER ONE IS
THAT IT'S A LACK OF. OF KIND OF
THESE MORE LONGER ESTABLISHED
RELATIONSHIPS WITH BANKS SO IF
WE CAN BREAK THOSE PROBLEMS AND
GET MORE INFORMATION OUT-
CREATE. YOU KNOW QUICK MORE.
YOU KNOW LIKE SHORTER TERM
ESTABLISHMENTS WITH BANKING OR
OTHER FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
THAT COULD REALLY HELP. OUR ONE
OF THE STATEMENTS JUST MADE A
MOVING FORWARD- THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES NEED TO HAVE MORE OF
AN ONLINE PRESENCE HOW DO YOU
PROPOSE THAT CONVERSATION START
WITH OUR SMALL BUSINESSES WHAT
DO WE DO. YEAH THAT'S A TOUGH
ONE TO- I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT COULD HELP. IS HOW
TARGETED FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
DIRECTLY FOR. CREATING WEB
PAGES FOR CREATING. YOU DON'T
WASTE THAT MAKE IT EASIER FOR
RESIDENTS TO SHOP ONLINE AND
LOCAL BUSINESSES. YOU KNOW WE
COULD ALSO TRY TO PUT A LITTLE
BIT CRUSHER ON SEARCH ENGINES.
AND TRY TO GET THEM TO
PRIORITIZE LOCAL BUSINESSES
RIGHT I MEAN THE PROBLEM THERE
IS A LOT OF THAT IS BASED ON AT
REVENANTS RIGHT AND THAT MAKES
IT MUCH MORE DIFFICULT. BUT YOU
KNOW MAYBE AT THIS POINT IN
TIME GIVEN THIS SEVERE CRISIS.
AND THIS. POTENTIAL WE'RE GONNA
LOSE SO MANY SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT THEY WILL MAKE AN
EXCEPTION. I'M THANK YOU SO
MUCH- THIS IS SUPER FASCINATING
AND I'M REALLY INTERESTED IN
SEEING HOW YOUR RESEARCH GOES
AND I THINK ALL OF US WOULD
LOVE TO HELP YOU GET THE DATA
YOU NEED BECAUSE THIS IS SUPER
VALUABLE- AND HELPING US TO
MAKE GOOD POLICY DECISIONS FOR
THE STATE. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I'VE THOUGHT ABOUT- AND
YOU KIND OF TOUCHED ON IT IN
YOUR PRESENTATION OF YOU DON'T
HAVE THE DATA THAT SIGN. I'M
WONDERING ABOUT THE EXPONENTIAL
IMPACTS OF MINORITY OWNED
BUSINESSES COMBINED WITH
COMMUNITIES THAT EXPERIENCE
HIGH UNEMPLOYMENT AND THEREFORE
THEY HAVE LOWER SPENDING
CAPACITY TO BE ABLE TO HELP
THOSE MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES
WHEN YOU LOOK AT SOME.
DIFFERENT AREAS OF THE STATE
HAVE YOU LOOKED AT THAT THAT
KIND OF ADDITIVE OR EXPONENTIAL
IMPACT WHERE YOU DON'T HAVE
SPENDING COME UP CAPACITY IN
THE COMMUNITY BECAUSE MAYBE
THEY'VE BEEN HARDER HIT BY
COVERT THEY'RE EXPERIENCING
MORE UNEMPLOYMENT THEREFORE
THEY HAVE LESS DISPOSABLE
INCOME. THAN THAT HOW THAT
RELATES TO HELPING- THE
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES WHO
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE
BEEN MORE SEVERELY IMPACTED
THIS THAT MAKES SENSE. YES IT
DOES. YOU KNOW SORT OF LOCAL
DOLLARS LOCAL I THINK IT'S KIND
OF THE SAME. THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT HERE. BUT I THINK
IT'S DEEPER THAN THAT THERE IS
A FAIR AMOUNT OF RESEARCH THAT
SHOWS THAT WHEN. YOU LOOK AT
THESE KIND OF SMALLER MINORIT
OWNED BUSINESSES. TEND TO HIRE.
COLLECT MIX SALUTE IF YOU LOOK
AT BLACK OWNED BUSINESSES FOR
EXAMPLE THEY TEND TO HIRE OTHER
AFRICAN AMERICANS IN THOSE
BUSINESSES THOSE JOBS OFTEN ARE
VERY LOCAL. THE SUPPORT THAT
COMMUNITY AND SO NOT ONLY ARE
YOU HELPING SMALL BUSINESSES.
IN TERMS OF THE OWNER AND
CREATING JOBS OVERALL YOU'RE
HELPING THE JOBS IN THAT
COMMUNITY AND THAT'S A
DISADVANTAGED AREA. THEN YOU'RE
HELPING THE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER YOU'RE HELPING CREATE
JOBS IN THAT LOCAL AREA. AND
YOUR CREATING WEALTH AND THAT
WEALTH OF COURSE ANY SPENT OR
AT LEAST IT'S MORE LIKELY TO BE
SPENT BACK IN THAT COMMUNITY.
AND SO THERE'S DEFINITELY THIS
MULTIPLIER. ANY OTHER COMMIT
MEMBERS WISHING ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU MADAM AT MIKE IS WILL
AROUND- THE SHUT THE REBOUND
AND THEN TIE BACK TO YOUR
SLIDE. AS FAR AS THE- SECTORS
THAT HAVE BEEN IMPACTED. BY
OCTOBER NINETEENTH. AND SO MY
FIRST QUESTION IS WITH THE SHUT
DOWNS- WHERE THEY DRIVEN BY
CERTAIN SECTORS MEANING- WERE
SOME OF THE SECTORS HIT HARDER.
THAN OTHERS- IN WHICH
BUSINESSES AND WHICH SECTORS
WHERE THEY- YES THAT WAS ONE
THING THAT WAS NICE IS BEING
ABLE TO GET THE SALES DATA
STATE CALIFORNIA. YOU COULD SEE
THAT ACCOMMODATIONS WAS THE ONE
THAT WAS HIT THE HARDEST. SO
THERE WAS A 90% DROP IN
REVENUES. TO THOSE BUSINESSES.
THAT IN SOME OF THE OTHER ONES
THAT WERE HIT HARD COURTS WERE.
HOURS WERE IT VERY HARD. NO BUT
A LOT OF SMALL SHOPS THAT WERE
SHUT DOWN SO CLOTHING. GIFT
SHOPS YOU KNOW THOSE TYPES OF
BUSINESSES WERE HIT EXTREMELY
HARD. AND WHEN YOU YOU TALKED
IN YOUR PRESENTATION OF A
REBOUND- WITH JOBS AND
BUSINESSES REBOUNDING OPENING
UP. DID THAT FOLLOW THE SECTORS
THAT WERE HARDEST HIT OVER
THOSE DIFFERENT SECTORS THAT
WE'RE CONTINUING TO EXPAND AND
REBOUND FROM THE CALL THE
NINETEEN- ECONOMIC IMPACT. SO I
DON'T HAVE THE DATA TIED TO
THOSE INDUSTRIES SO I WAS
FOCUSED PRIMARILY ON YOUR
QUARTER TILL TWENTY TWENTY. SO
I THINK THAT THAT'S YOU KNOW
THAT IT IS BECOMING AVAILABLE
AND WILL BE ABLE TO STUDY THAT
SAM AND SEE WHERE THE REBOUNDS
WERE SPECIFICALLY- YOU KNOW
TARGET. THANK YOU AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THAT BAD
INFORMATION SO WE COULD
PINPOINT- CERTAINLY THOSE THAT
ARE REBOUNDING BUT THEN THOSE
THAT THAT HAPPENED. THAT NEEDS
SOME ADDED- ADVOCACY FOR THEM I
WANT TO THANK YOU ON YOUR SLIDE
UP SHOWING. UP WITHIN THE
GROWTH A SALES GROWTH
PERCENTAGE. AND SOME OF THE
SECTORS THAT WOULD DRASTICALLY
HIT BY. THE IMPACT OF TWELVE
NINETEEN BUT ALSO- SHOWING THAT
SOME BUSINESS SECTORS CONTINUED
TO HAVE A GROWTH PERIOD- DURING
THIS TIME. SO THAT THAT WHAT
I'M IN IN MY MIND ALLOW US TO
FOCUS OUR ENERGY ON THE TRUE
BUSINESSES THAT ARE BEING
IMPACTED. BY COVERT NINETEEN SO
THAT WE CAN GET ALL OF THEM
REBOUNDING BACK INTO THE
ECONOMY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY SOUTH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I HAVE A SIMILAR
QUESTION TALKED FAIRLY- ONE OF
YOUR EARLIER SAW SLIGHT
INDICATE THAT THE ASIAN
BUSINESSES ARE. SOMEWHAT SLOWER
AND RECOVERY- COMPARED TO THE
OTHER GROUP SO. I WAS WONDERING
WHETHER OR NOT DO YOU HAVE ANY
OF. DATA SHOWING THE BREAKDOWN
BY INDUSTRY OR BY SECTORS
REGARDING THESE BUSINESSES.
WHEN I DID SOME OF MY EARLIER
WORK I DO TRY TO. KIND OF FOCUS
ON INDUSTRY DIFFERENCES ABOUT
WAS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
FOUND IS THAT ASIAN BUSINESS
OWNERS AND ACTUALLY OTHER
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES.
TENDED TO BE IN INDUSTRIES THAT
WERE SHUT DOWN MORE IN APRIL IN
OTHER INDUSTRIES. SO ONE GOOD
EXAMPLE IS AGRICULTURE'S ONE OR
IF IT'S DONE WELL IF YOU LOOK
AT THE OWNERS OF AGRICULTURAL
BUSINESSES THEY TENDED NOT BE
MINORITY ALL. YOU DON'T WORKERS
OFTEN ARE MINORITY WORKERS IN
THOSE INDUSTRIES BUT NOT THE
OWNERS OF THE BUSINESSES SO YOU
THINK IT YOU KNOW I'M TALKING
NATIONALLY HERE- THAT A LOT OF
THE FARM OWNERS ARE. ARE- ARE
NOT A MINORITY OWNS IT SO THAT
DADS ROLL SOME OF THE
DIFFERENCES BUT ALSO JUST
INDUSTRIES THAT HAVE A LOT OF
PERSON TO PERSON CONTACT YOU
KNOW YOU THINK OF. BARBER SHOPS
NAIL SALONS REALLY SMALL RETAIL
STORES THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT
WERE KIND OF HIT THE HARDEST
YOU KNOW EARLY ON WITH CLOSURES
AND HAVE SEEN THIS KIND OF. YOU
KNOW OPENING SHUTTING DOWN
OPENING YOU DON'T RE OPENING.
AND SO I THINK THAT'S A BIG
PART OF IT. LET ME GO AND TURN
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER MANY. AND A
WALL GO. THIS MEMBER KARTI
PETRIE-NORRIS. THANK YOU DOCTOR
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION. BUT MOST
OF IT WAS ON A NATIONAL LEVEL.
I WANT TO HOPE THAT WE GET MORE
INFORMATION AND DATA TO YOU. SO
WE CAN ZERO IN CALIFORNIA AND
BREAK IT ALL THE WAY DOWN INTO
THE COUNTIES. OF THE FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES IN CALIFORNIA
LET ALONE TO INDUSTRIES. BUT
THE RURAL COMMUNITY VERSUS
URBAN CITIES AND- AN EXTRA
LAYER OF BREAK DOWN. SO WE KNOW
EXACTLY WHERE. WERE HIT
HARDEST. IN THE FUNDING THAT
NEEDS TO BE A RESOURCE BACK TO
THOSE COMMUNITIES- TO BE
AFFECTED MORE. BECAUSE I THINK
IN THE LONG RUN. URBAN CITIES.
HAVE BEEN HIT AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN HIT TO
PROBABLY TWICE AS HARD. SO I'D
LIKE TO SEE A BREAKDOWN AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET TO THAT
DATA THAT YOU NEED. ON A VERY
EXPEDITIOUSLY. TIMELINE SO WE
GET THE DATA BACK US VERY. AND
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR. THANK
YOU DOCTOR FIVE THIRTEEN HERE
AND FOR YOUR PRESENTATION-
PENTOMIC CERTAINLY HAS
HIGHLIGHTED AND EXACERBATED
FUNDAMENTAL INEQUITIES. ARE ALL
ACROSS THE STATE AND- CERTAINLY
AMONGST OUR OUR SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITIES AS WELL- CLEAR
PRIORITY FOR THIS COMMITTEE AND
FOR THAT THE LEGISLATURE
OVERALL IS TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
DIRECTING FINANCIAL RESOURCES
AND RELIEF. TO BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE BEEN HARDEST HIT
PARTICULARLY IN HISTORICALLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES YOU
MENTIONED SOME OF THE HURDLES
THAT EXISTS NOT JUST IN OUR
STATE BUT ACROSS THE COUNTRY IN
TERMS OF ENSURING THAT THEY
DOLLARS ACTUALLY FLOATS YOU HI.
YOU MINORITY OWNED AND MANAGED
BUSINESSES ARE THEIR MODELS IN
OTHER STATES THAT WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT- THEY HAVE AND
SUCCESSFULLY BROKEN DOWN. THOSE
BARRIERS ARE THERE ARE THERE
LESSONS THAT WE CAN LEARN A
CALIFORNIA POLICY MAKERS- FROM
SUCCESSES IN OTHER STATES. I AM
NOT ACTUALLY LOOKED- ACROSS
DIFFERENT STATES YOU KNOW WHAT
MOST OF MY RESEARCH HAS BEEN
FOCUSED CAN MORE BROADLY ON THE
U. S. AND THEN OF COURSE THE
BIG PROGRAMS LIKE THE TPP
PROGRAM IN THE IDYLLWILD
GROUNDS AND OF COURSE THE
RESEARCH THAT I'VE BEEN DOING
THAT CALIFORNIA. SO I HAVEN'T
REALLY LOOKED THAT MUCH ACROSS
STATES I HAVEN'T HEARD YOU KNOW
FROM THE GROUPS AND
ORGANIZATIONS THAT I'VE BEEN
TALKING TO ABOUT. ANY STATE
HAVING LIKE A SPECIFICALLY NO
REALLY WELL TARGETED OR WEALTH
SHE PROGRAM RIGHT NOW. OKAY
YEAH I THINK. CERTAINLY DID
THAT THE DOW THAT YOU SHOWED
FROM THAT THAT PPP PROGRAM. ONE
VERSUS PPP PROGRAM RUN TO
CERTAINLY DOES DRIVE HOME THE
POINT THAT I'VE- THAT BEING
INTENTIONAL. AND I'VE BEEN
FOCUSED ON ON OUTREACH CAN
HAVE. REALLY REALLY MEANINGFUL
IMPACT- CITING TAX INCREASING
USE AS WE LOOK. AS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO BE AT THE SUBSEQUENT
ROUND OF FUNDING AFTER
CALIFORNIA'S COMPUTER RELIEF
GRAPHS. THANK YOU SEE. NO OTHER
QUESTIONS ARE LET ME JUST AGAIN
THANK YOU DOCTOR FOR JOINING US
TODAY. I LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
CONTINUED COLLABORATION AND I
MAYBE JUST GO IN AND DIGESTING
SOME OF THIS INFORMATION SEEM
WHERE WE CAN GO FROM HERE BUT
BUT LET ME GO AHEAD AND MOVE TO
OUR NEXT ITEM. ON THE AGENDA. I
AM NUMBER FOUR. JUST START WILL
THE SPEAKERS FOR NEXT PANEL
PLEASE AND MEET THEIR BIKES AND
UP IN THEIR VIDEO SETTINGS I
MEMBERS DURING THIS AGENDA ITEM
WE WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
HERE FROM SEVERAL OF OUR
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AND HOW THE
STATE AND ITS PARTNERS HAVE
ACTIVATED IT ADOPTED PROGRAMS
TO MEET THE CHALLENGES OF COVER
NINETEEN INDUCED RECESSION
PLEASE WELCOME JAMES WATSON
PRESIDENT OF THE CAIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING TECHNOLOGY
CONSULTING WE HAVE A DNA CRIME
BO. EXACTED DIRECTOR OF
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
CORPORATE TRAINING AT ST
BERNARD DINO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT WE ALSO HAD BIANCA
BLOOM QUEST SENIOR MANAGER
CALIFORNIA POLICY ENGAGEMENT
SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY ABOUT
REALLY RATHER THAN HAVING
ANOTHER PRESENTATION WE'RE JUST
GOING TO DO I CHANGE IT UP
REALLY QUICKLY DO A QUICK Q. NA
AND SO WE CAN EACH. IF WE CAN
GET EACH PANELIST TO MAKE A
BRIEF TWO MINUTE INTRODUCTION
THEN THAT WILL BE FOLLOWED BY
QUESTIONS AND DIALOGUE WITH THE
COMMITTEE MISTER WATSON WOULD
YOU PLEASE START US OFF BY.
WITH THE WORD ABOUT YOURSELF IN
YOUR ORGANIZATION. SURE SURE
THANK YOU MUCH I LIKE TO THE
CHAIR THE COMMITTEE. INVITING I
AM THE PER AND CEO OF SEEM TO
SEE- COME ON NO AS A CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING TECHNOLOGY
CONSULTING GROUP- WE ARE TASKED
WITH PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO SMALL AND MEDIUM
SIZE MANUFACTURERS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. WE HAVE THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND MANUFACTURERS IN OUR
STATE IN 70% OF THEM ARE. LESS
THAN SEVENTY LESS THAN TWENTY
EMPLOYEES- SO WE ARE STATE OF A
VERY SMALL MANUFACTURERS. YOUR
MISSION IS REALLY TO PROVIDE
SOLUTIONS THAT WILL HELP
IMPROVE THEIR PRODUCTIVITY. AND
THE COMPETITIVENESS- THE
PROTECTED PRODUCTIVITY SIDE IS
REALLY IMPORTANT BECASE WE ARE
HIGH COST MANUFACTURING STATE.
SOME SAY THERE'S A 20% PREMIUM
TO MANUFACTURE IN OUR STATE SO
THE IDEA OF GETTING THEIR
PRODUCTS- MATOS AS
INEXPENSIVELY AS POSSIBLE TO BE
COMPETITIVE IS A VERY STRONG-
VISION FOR US. WE'RE ALSO
TRYING TO IMPROVE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING IN THE PUBLIC
GOOD WE DEFINE THE PUBLIC GOOD
IS. WHAT ARE WHAT DOES THE WORK
WE DO TO OUR CUSTOMERS PROVIDE
TO DISTANCE GDP IN REVENUE
JOBS- TWO YEARS AGO WE DID A
RESEARCH THAT FOUND THAT THE
IMPACT FROM OUR- OUR BUSINESSES
WE WORK WITH MADE ABOUT THREE
POINT SEVEN. BILLION DOLLARS
INFUSION THE PEOPLE STATE.
HELLO WE LOOK WE LOOK AT MAN
VERSUS PEOPLE WHEN WE CAL OUR
METRIC- PROVIDED ASSISTANCE
LAST YEAR IT IS SIXTY EIGHT TO
SIX THOUSAND A HUNDRED AND TEN
MANUFACTURE- OUR PROGRAM FUNDED
WITH A CO DEGREE THROUGH THEIR
APARTMENT IN THE NATIONAL
STUDENTS INTO. WE HAVE A
COOPERATIVE AGREEMENT FOR A
BASE FUNDING WE ALSO HAVE A
COLLECTIVE AGREEMENT FOR
CARRIAGE ACT FUNDING WE ALSO
HAVE AN AGREEMENT WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE
SMALL BUSINESS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WHICH IS
ADMINISTERED BY GO BIZ AND LAST
YEAR I'M SORRY FROM MARCH OF
LAST YEAR TO MARCH OF THIS YEAR
WE PROVIDED ASSISTANCE TO SEVEN
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY
SIX MANUFACTURERS SO THE PACE
OF OUR PROVIDING ASSISTANCE IS
PICKING UP. THANK YOU AND IF WE
COULD JUST HOLD QUESTIONS UNTIL
I EACH OF THE PANELISTS HAS
INTRODUCED I MISS CURRENT B. O.
WOULD YOU PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF IN THE COMMUNITY CALL.
CONTRACT EDUCATION CENTERS.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ENSURE CERVANTES. I'M DEANNA
CRANIAL AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AT TECHNOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IN CORPORATE
TRAINING SEMINAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STATEWIDE
COLLABORATIVE. UPSCALE IN
ADDITION TO COLLABORATING
STATEWIDE WE WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH OUR NEIGHBORS RIVERSIDE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT'S
CONTRACT EDUCATION UNIT
REPRESENTING NORCO RIVERSIDE
CITY. I'M WORRIED ABOUT THE
COLLEGES. THE PURPOSE OF
CONTACT EDUCATION AS TO PROVIDE
A RAPID RESPONSE AND CUSTOMIZED
SHORT TERM PROGRAMS THAT OFFER
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY AND
VITALITY SUPPORT ASSISTANCE
THROUGH TRAINING EMPLOYMENT AND
WORKFORCE AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. CONTRACT EDUCATION
PROVIDES IMPROVES THE LIVES OF
ITS LOCAL COMMUNITY BY
PROVIDING LIFELONG APPS KILLING
ALL POPULATIONS TO STAY
COMPETITIVE IN THEIR THIRTY TO
FORTY YEAR CAREER SPORTING
TECHNOLOGICAL CHANGES. IN THE
WORKFORCE AND PROMOTING
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY THROUGH
WAGE GAINS CONTRACT EDUCATION
DOES NOT RECEIVE ANY FUNDING
FROM THE STATE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE NORTH FROM STRONG
WORKFORCE MANY. A OP BY
OBTAINING PUB AND CONTRACTS
GRANTS ASSETS ARE LIMITED BY
HOW MUCH FUNDING THEY CAN
CHANGE AND BY THE RQUIREMENTS
OF THOSE CONTRACTS AND GRANTS
TRANSECTED CATION IS NOT
OPERATING AT MAXIMUM CAPACITY
DO YOU GET THE SPENDING
CONSTRAINTS. LAST YEAR DURING
THE PANDEMIC FOR EXAMPLE ECG
WHICH IS THE ONLY ONE OF FORTY
FIVE CONTRACT EDUCATION UNITS
SURE SIX HUNDRED AND SIXTY TWO
INCUMBENT WORKERS ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY JUSTICE INVOLVED
INDIVIDUALS. AND 42% OF THE
BUSINESSES SERVED WERE SMALL
BUSINESSES. IN TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN WE SERVED ONE THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTY IN
COMBAT WORKERS. WE PLACED
NINETY SEVEN JUSTICE INVOLVED
INDIVIDUALS INTO FULL TIME
EMPLOYMENT AND SEVENTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER PERSON PER
YEAR TO INCARCERATE THEM. AS A
TOTAL ANNUAL SAVINGS TO THE
STATE OF SEVEN MILLION.
600-636-3000 DOLLARS. WITH
FUNDING MANAGING WHAT WE CAN DO
ACROSS THE STATE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISPRINT QUEST IF YOU
COULD PLEASE MAKE YOUR
INTRODUCTION AND TALK ABOUT THE
SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY. SURE
I'D LOVE TO YOU AND GOOD
MORNING AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME MEMBERS OF THE JEDI
COMMITTEE ENSURE WOMEN
CERVANTES- I'M BIANCA AND
GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE WITH YOU HOW WE CAN
BETTER SUPPORT SMALL BUSINESS
CAPITAL NEEDS AT THIS TIME.
SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY IS A
RESEARCH AND EDUCATIONAL
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION AND WE
ARE FIVE OH ONE SEE THREE THEN
EMPOWERS APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
AND ENTREPRENEURS. TO BUILD A
THRIVING AND EQUITABLE ECONOMY.
THREE PANDA NEAR ONE ENFORCED
BUSINESS OWNERS DID NOT HAVE AN
ACCOUNT WITH THE CREDIT UNION
OR A TRADITIONAL BANKS. THE
NUMBER IS EVEN HIGHER FOR
ENTREPRENEURS OF COLOR AND
WOMEN. BUSINESS OWNERS OF COLOR
TEAM LESS FINANCING THAN THEIR
WHITE COUNTERPARTS BY OVER TEN
PERCENTAGE POINTS ACCORDING TO
OUR- SURVEY THAT WAS JUST
RELEASED TODAY. ONE QUARTER OF
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS OVERALL
HAVE BEEN DENIED ALONE. FEDERAL
PROGRAMS LIKE TV KEY ARE
CRUCIAL INDEED BUT LESS THAN
HALF OF CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS HAVE EVEN
APPLIED. IT'S CLEAR TO US THAT
THE LACK OF THAT THINKING IT
RELATIONSHIP CONTINUES TO
INHIBIT BLACK AND BROWN
BUSINESS OWNERS FROM ACCESSING
FINANCING. WE'RE THRILLED THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS COMMITTED
TO MORE FUNDING FOR THE GRANT
RELIEF PROGRAMS HELPING SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS OF THE STATE
DOES NOT END WITH THE GRANT
PROGRAM CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
INVEST SERIOUSLY INTO ITS
CURRENT INFRASTRUCTURE. TO
ENSURE LONG TERM RECOVERY FOR
WOMEN BUSINESS OWNERS OF COLOR
AND MINORITY OTHER ROLE AND
MINORITY ENTREPRENEURS. THE
CALIFORNIA REBUILDING FUND IS
THE BEST- OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE
SYSTEMIC CHANGE IN THE SPACE IT
IS A PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP
BUT IT'S DESIGNED TO AND IT'S
DESIGNED TO SUSTAIN SMALL
BUSINESS LONG TERM. RECOVERY
NEEDS. THREE BUILDING FUND
LEVERAGES GOVERNMENT BACK
CAPITAL AND PROVIDE LIQUIDITY
FOR CDFI IS TO MAKE MORE LOANS
TO SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS OF
COLOR AND MAYNOR AND WOMEN
BUSINESS OWNERS. SUCH AS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PREPARES TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL RELIEF BUT
BY AND THE ESSENCE PCORI AND
OTHER PROGRAMS WE HOPE YOU WILL
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN A PATH TO
LONG TERM SUSTAINABILITY THAT
OUR LOCAL. MOM AND POP SHOPS
WILL NEED. IN FACT WE FOR IT'S
MY BUSINESS SUPPORT PUBLIC
POLICIES. LIKE THREE BUILDINGS
I'D BE HAPPY TO AND I'M TO
SHARE THOSE RESULTS WITH YOU
THROUGHOUT MY TESTIMONY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
RODRIGUEZ PHD FOR COMING AND I
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN WITH THE
QUESTION FOR THE WHOLE PANEL
WHAT IS THE SINGLE MOST
IMPORTANT ACTION THE STATE CAN
TAKE TO SUPPORT LOCAL. ECONOMIC
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
ACTIVITIES AGAIN AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. SH. IT COULD BE A
QUESTION TO OUR ANY OF THE
PANELISTS THAT COULD TAKE ON
IT'S. ARE WE NEED NOT INVEST IN
THE LONG TERM SUSTAINABLE.
CAPITANEEDS AND SMALL OFFICE
OWNERS IS GOING TO BE CREWS.
MANY OF THE PROGRAMS THAT WE
ABOUT- ARE ARE CRITICAL FOR
SHORT TERM. MEDIA LEAST BUT THE
CAP FOR RECALL SIGN A PROGRAM
THAT SYSTEM SMALL BUSINESS THE
NEXT AS LONG AS. IF THIS YOUR
WATER I THINK THIS A COUPLE-
THEY CAN GO IN A FIRST OF ALL
WE AND THIS IS WEEK I'M STILL
FROM STEM RIGHT. WORKFORCE'S
RULING ENOUGH WORK AND GETTING
NEW SKILL WORKERS IN THE MANY-
COMMUNITY. I THINK I CERTAINLY
LIKE TO SEE. WELL THE AND
INCREASE IN EMPLOYMENT PARA
PROGRAM AND WE'RE REDUCE THIS
YEAR TO A MILLION TO. I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE ANOTHER FIFTY MONEY
DOLLARS IN THAT PROBE- IT IS
70% OF THE ETPB EMPLOYERS THAT
ARE IN THAT PROGRAM. OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND CUSTOMERS THE
NORTHRIDGE STUDY INDICATED THAT
THE TRAINING ITSELF PROVIDES
REALLY GREAT DIVIDENDS FOR NOT
ONLY WAGE. BUT A GOOD ARE ALIVE
FROM- FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND SECONDLY- TH
STATE NEEDS TO CONTINUE TO-
FIND. TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WE AS I SAID EARLIER WE ARE A
HIGH COST STATE- IN TERMS OF
MANUFACTURING OUR
MANUFACTURERS- NEED HELP NOT
ONLY WITH COST CONTROL BUT THEY
ALSO NEED HELP I THINK ROBERT
MENTIONED IT. ON. THESE DAYS.
ARE GOING TO E. COMMERCE AND
IF- MANUFACTURER DOESN'T HAVE
ANY COMMERCE PLATFORM. AND IS
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THAT
THAT FORM OF BUSINESS AND ARE
NOT DIGITALLY SAVVY. THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE A PROBLEM. THE
OTHER IS I THINK YOU SHOULD GET
WE'VE SHOULD CONTINUE ANY KIND
OF TAX OR OTHER INCENTIVES THAT
GIVE OTHER STIMULATE GROWTH FOR
MANUFACTURING- LET'S CLOSE GIVE
A REASON FOR MANUFACTURED A
MODEST EXPAND THEIR BUSINESS.
IN CALIFORNIA. EXACTLY THIS IS
A BIG ASK- YOU KNOW THE WHOLE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND EASY
ACCESS TO PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
IS VITAL TO MANUFACTURING.
WE'RE FINDING IS A MIGRATION OF
WORKERS MOVING FROM THE COASTAL
COMMUNITIES TO BE AN EMPIRE. OR
FROM THE COASTAL COMMUNITIES IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY WHICH IS
CALLED AN EXTREMELY LONG
COMMUTES. AND THOSE COMMUTER
ARE CAUSING ISSUES WITH
TURNOVER JOB TURNOVER BECAUSE A
LONG COMMUTE WILL TYPICALLY
LEAD TO TURN OVER AND- IN A
POSITION. WHICH LEAVES
MANUFACTURERS NOW. TRYING TO
DEAL WITH THE PROBLEM. ALTHOUGH
THEY HAD EVEN THE PAN WHICH IS
WHICH IS FOR SKILLED WORKERS
AND I. THANK YOU SO MUCH IF I
COULD TURN TO THIS CURRENT B.
O. AGAIN WHAT IS THE SINGLE
MOST IMPORTANT ACTION THE STATE
CAN TAKE TO SUPPORT. LOCAL
ECONOMIC AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT ACTIVITIES AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. THANK YOU CHAIR
CERVANTES ON. THIS THE
CHALLENGES WE CONTINUE TO SEE
RIGHT NOW IS ACCESS TO SKILLED
WORKFORCE- IN BECAUSE OF CODE
THAT WE HAVE THE ADDED
CHALLENGE OF WORKING IN A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT AND WORKING WITH
MANY PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING ARE
VIRTUALLY FROM HONG. I BELIEVE
THAT IF WE- WERE TO INVEST INTO
CONTRACT EDUCATION. OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IS THE
LARGEST COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM IN THE WORLD IN
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE OVER A
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND WE HAVE FORTY FIVE
CONTRACT EDUCATION UNITS THAT
ARE WORKING. ON THE FIVE YEAR
DATA FOR THOSE- FOR CONTRACT
EDUCATION UPSCALE PROGRAMS WE
204-500-0600 FIFTY FOUR
INDIVIDUALS FROM THREE THOUSAND
EMPLOYERS. THE AVERAGE CHAINING
GATE RANGE WAS 20% AND THE
PARTICIPATION RETENTION RATE
WAS 97% THE AVERAGE COST FOR
FORTY HOURS OF TRAINING WAS
ONLY EIGHT HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FIVE DOLLARS AND THE REVENUE IN
TAX RATE BACK TO THE CUTS THE
STATE FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DOLLARS. CONTRACT INDICATION IS
THE STATE'S TRAINING ARM WE DO
WORK WITH THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANEL. AND AGAIN WE
DON'T HAVE ANY FUNDING COMING
FROM THE STATE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE. AND I FEEL THAT IF WE
WERE TO INVEST INTO CONTRACT
EDUCATION. WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
REACH THAT THE INDIVIDUALS THE
MARGINALIZED INDIVIDUALS AND
COME BACK INTO WORK. THANK YOU
YOUR ARE IN THEIR MOM AND ASK
ONE QUESTION AND THEN TURN IT
OVER TO OUR THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS TO THE PANELISTS.
MISTER WATSON A NEW DRESS MAYBE
THE NEEDS- OR REPHRASE IS
ACTUALLY A HOW HAVE THE NEEDS
OF BUSINESSES USE SERVING THE
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY CHANGED
SINCE MARCH OF LAST YEAR.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND
THANK YOU FOR THAT- IN ORDER TO
KNOW WHAT IS CHANGED TO WE
PROBABLY HAVE TO CONSIDER WHERE
IT CAME FROM. THE PANDEMIC OF
THE KEY ELEMENTS OF- AND WE GET
THIS FROM EVERY YEAR WE SURVEY
OUR MANUFACTURERS TO DETERMINE.
WHAT THEIR NEEDS ARE AND
INVARIABLY EVERY YEAR GROWTH IS
THE NUMBER ONE NEED THEIR THEIR
ABILITY TO GROW THEIR
BUSINESSES. SECONDLY WAS
WORKFORCE TRYING TO SOLVE THE
SKILLED WORKER PROBLEM- THAT
WAS MENTIONED BEFORE AND THEN
THE OTHERS COST CONTROL AND
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT TO
INCREASE PRODUCTIVITY SO THAT
WAS THAT'S KIND OF THE
LANDSCAPE BEFORE. AFTER AND-
ACCESS CAPITAL ROAD WHITE TO
TOP THE NEEDS OF FINANCING BE
ON PPP PPP- THERE ARE THERE ARE
ALWAYS THESE AND COVER THEIR
OVERHEAD BUT IT DIDN'T GIVE
THEM WHAT THEY NEEDED TO
CONTENT TO TRY AND WIN THIS
THEY LOST DURING- DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND BY THE WAY I
ROBERTS CHART MIRRORS WHAT WAS
HAPPENING MANUFACTURING I THINK
HIS CHART SHOWED THAT IN APRIL
OF WAS A 15% REDUCTION I THINK
MANUFACTURING WHICH WAS AN AREA
OF 20% INITIALLY AND IS AS SLOW
EVERY RECOVERED. THIS IS YOUR
OUT OF MAINTAIN THE STATE
WORKPLACE- YOU KNOW TO REDUCE-
IN THE WORK. BECAUSE OF CALL ED-
YOU KNOW AS AS WE AT POSTPONED
MAKE IT STOP IDEA OF NOT GROW
THEIR- IT'S A ALL I DO OF
TRYING TO. GET REPLACE THE
BUSINESS THAT THEY'VE LOST AND
THIS IS WHERE OUR SALES AND
MARKETING AND SCO- YOU KNOW. SO
YOU KNOW THE SEARCH ENGINE
OPTIMIZATION ALL THE THINGS
COME BACK IN AGAIN. AND
HONESTLY SUPPLY CHAIN AND
OPERATIONAL DISRUPTIONS- ARE
HAVE RISEN TO THE TOP AS WELL
THAT YOU KNOW THESE THESE
MANUFACTURERS COLLECTED THE
MATERIALS. I CAN'T DELIVER
THEIR CUSTOMERS ON TIME AND
COLBY DISCUSSED MOP RACIAL DATA
DISRUPTIONS WITHIN THE PLAN
ITSELF. WHICH IS CAUSING- THEIR
INABILITY. TO GET THE PRODUCTS
OUT AS WELL. BUT IF I COULD
POSE A SINGLE TO- THERE'S WAS.
FOR AS THIS NEED TO TRAIN THEIR
ON HOW TO WORK FROM HOME
VIRTUALLY INCLUDING HOW TO
SUPERVISE AND MANAGE THEIR
EMPLOYEES. HOW TO DEAL WITH
VIRTUAL CHALLENGES AND SELF
MANAGEMENT SKILLS FIRST INITIAL
WORKERS BUSINESSES NEEDED
COVERED NINETEEN AND SHE SAFETY
IN CHANGE MANAGEMENT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK IN A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT. IN ADDITION THERE
WAS AN INCREASED NEED FOR
DIVERSITY EQUITY AND INCLUSION
TRAINING AN EXAMPLE OF
DIVERSITY TRAINING IS A
PARTNERSHIP WE HAD WITH EASY
YEP. BOB COMPANY THEY TRAINED
ONE HUNDRED OF THEIR EMPLOYEES
IN IN CUSTOMIZED DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION TRAINING WHICH WAS
DELIVERED BOTH VIRTUALLY IN
SPANISH AND IN ENGLISH. WANTED
TO ALSO POINT OUT THAT WE ALSO
PARTNER WITH THE WE'RE THE
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT BOARDS AND
WE ALSO DIDN'T ACTUALLY PARTNER
WITH CMCC. I MEAN YEAH REALLY
CRACK ANYTHING FROM WHAT THE
PANELISTS HAVE SHARED AND IN
RESPONSE TO YOUR FIRST QUESTION
ABSOLUTELY I THINK IT ALL
UNDERSCORES INVESTMENT AND LONG
TERM GROWTH OPPORTUNITIES. KEY
FOR SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS IN
CALIFORNIA I DID WANT TO TOUCH
ON DOCTOR FARLEY'S-
ILLUMINATING PRESENTATION. ON
THAT DATE IT WAS. INCREDIBLE
INVESTING IN THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE- TO ENSURE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS. IN THE RIGHT.
AND WELL AS IN RURAL AREAS-
MAKING SURE THEY CAN ACCESS THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE BUT MANY
OF OUR PARTNERS PROVIDE THE
KENNEL LESS HONEST. IN THIS
HEARING AS WELL AS OUR SMALL
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT CENTERS
AND WOMEN'S BUSINESS CENTERS OR
ISN'T LEGAL ACTS. EAGLE
VOLUNTEERS. TO HELP THEM ALSO
UNDERSTAND THEIR COMPLIANCE
MEASURES I THINK WE ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT. HOW THE OUR BUSINESS
OWNERS NEEDS HAVE CHANGED FROM
THE LAST YEAR AGAIN I'D LIKE TO
SITE AND SOME OF OUR DATA THAT
JUST CAME OUT AND THIS MORNING
ACTUALLY- SHOWS THAT 80% OF
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS ARE
STRUGGLING TO. HE THEIR RENT
THOSE TO OPERATE COMMERCIAL
SPACES ESPECIALLY OVER HALF OF
THESE ARE WANT ONE MORE MONTH.
TO RENT AND MORTGAGE 20% F
THESE BUSINESS OWNERS HAVE BEEN
THREATENED WITH EVICTION. WHILE
HALF OF THESE FOLKS HAVE
RECEIVED ET THOSE NUMBERS WERE
LARGELY SKEWED TOWARDS- WHITE
BUSINESS OWNERS HI THIS IS 63%
OF WHITE BUSINESS OWNERS
COMPARED TO AT 2032% OF BLACK
BUSINESS OWNERS- SO INVESTING
AGAIN IN LONG TERM RECOVERY
EFFORTS LIKE THE CALIFORNIA
REBUILDING FIND IS GOING TO BE
A STRATEGY TO. ADDRESS THESE
INEQUITIES AT SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY WE HAVE HELPED OVER
THIRTY FIVE TOUSAND BUSINESS
OWNERS WHO HAVE REGISTERED FOR
EITHER OUR POLICY. UPDATES WERE
EDUCATIONAL WORKSHOPS IN THE
PAST YEAR WE'VE ADDED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND NEW BUSINESS
OWNERS INSURANCE NETWORK
ALTHOUGH WE'RE NOT MEMBERSHIP
BASED MOST OF THESE BUSINESS
OWNERS IMAGE RUN NETWORK
THROUGH OUR EDUCATIONAL
ACTIVITIES OR OUR- MEDIA WORK.
NEARLY FIVE HUNDRED IN LAST
YEAR SO I THINK THAT. WE CAN
ALL AGREE THAT THAT BUSINESS
OWNERS- HAVE DEFINITELY REACHED
OUT TO THE PARTNERS OR HELP.
THANK YOU. LET ME TURN OVER TO
SOME WORKING NUMBERS
PROTECTIONS. I'M THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IT ACTUALLY. THE
FIRM JAMES WATSON ONE OF MY
QUESTIONS WAS IN REGARDS TO THE
POLICIES THAT WE CAN DO IS A
LEGISLATOR TO KEEP
MANUFACTURING CALIFORNIA. BUT
I'D LIKE TO SEE MORE INVESTMENT
IN THE WORK FORCE DEVELOPMENT
TO TRAIN OUR NEXT GENERATION.
OF MANUFACTURERS BUT WE GOT TO
MAKE SURE THAT. MANUFACTURES IN
CALIFORNIA. AND- I DON'T THINK
HE'S GOING TO COME UP ON THE
SCREEN. AND IN ME AS I HAVE UP
BEYOND COULD THERE- CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATORS APPROVED A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AND
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET. HOW MUCH OF THAT MONEY
AND LOANS HAVE BEEN GIVEN OUT.
AND THE AMOUNT OF THE LOANS.
ANY DO YOU HAVE ANY OF THAT
DATA. IT'S AVAILABLE IS
SOMEWHAT LIMITED HOWEVER I CAN
TELL YOU THAT OVER TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN LOANS HAVE
BEEN MADE. I THE AVERAGE LOAN
SIZE HAS BEEN APPROXIMATELY
SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH I
THINK UNDERSCORES THE FACT THAT
THESE LOANS ARE INDEED.
TARGETING SMALL TO MICRO
BUSINESS OWNERS THOSE WHO HAVE
LESS THAN TEN ALSO LESSEN FIVE.
BUSINESSES I AND THE MAJORITY
OF THE LOANS THAT HAVE BEEN
NEED ARCH YOU- WORLD BUSINESS
OWNERS OR WOMEN WERE. THANK YOU
THAT WAS BECAUSE I WAS GOING
FOLLOW UP DISCUSSION FOR THE
MINORITIES AND THEN- THAT THE-
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES IN THE.
STATE SO THANKS FOR ANSWERING
THAT OUT FRONT. CAN WE GET YOU
MISTER WHITE. ARM YEAH. THE
MOMENT. THANK YOU OKAY I'M NOT
SURE IF YOU'RE MICHAEL AND YEAH
pWAS ON SO YEAH- YOUR QUESTION
IS HOW DO WE- YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT CAN BUT COLLEGE DO TO KEEP-
YOU KNOW MANUFACTURE AND CAL
THROUGH WORK AND THERE'S A
THINGS FIRST OF ALL THERE'S
THE- INVESTING IN TRAINING THE
INCUMBENT WORKERS BECAUSE
INCOME WORKERS ARE THE BEST
WORKING THE BEST WORKING AB IS
WHEN YOU HAVE IT WAS WHEN YOU
GOT. SO WE DO NEED TO CONTINUE
TO INVEST IN INCOME PER WORKER
TRAINING IN THE SECOND OF ALL
IF YOU GOT TO BUILD A BETTER
BRIDGE. BETWEEN ACADEMIA THAT
IS TRAINING FOLKS FOR
MANUFACTURING AND INDUSTRY AND
I THINK- YOU KNOW WE WORK WITH.
A LOT OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES- WE WORK WITH A LOT OF
UNIVERSITIES. YOU KNOW TRYING
TO BUILD THIS BRIDGE BETWEEN-
YOU KNOW NEW GRADUATES ARE
COMING OUT- WHO HAVE.
UNBELIEVABLE SKILLS IN
ENGINEERING UNBELIEVABLE SKILLS
IN AND WORKING- YOU KNOW TOOLS
AND EQUIPMENT WITHIN
MANUFACTURING HOW DO WE GET
THEM INTO MANUFACTURING-
THROUGH SOME KIND OF AN
APPRENTICE PROGRAM. OR HOW
COULD WE GET HOW CAN WE FIND.
MANY FACTIONS JIM BEST IN IN
NEW EMPLOYEES THAT. COME OUT OF
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR
UNIVERSITY NETWORK. THANK YOU
MISTER WALKER THE- DIFFERENCE
IS A MEMBER RAMOS THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND- MISTER WATSON
SINCE YOU'RE ON THE SCREEN. IN
THE STATE- IS THERE ANY DATA
BASED ON THE REGIONS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF SHOWING THE
IMPACTS OF THE GREATEST
IMPERFECTION IN THOSE REGIONS
THEN PUT A LOOP TO SOME OF THE
DIFFERENT GROWTH FACTORS OR
DECLINE IN JOBS IN CERTAIN
SECTORS IN CERTAIN AREAS. IN
THE STATE. YEAH YEAH THERE IS-
THERE THERE'S A COUPLE OF
REGIONS IN THE STATE THAT WERE
REALLY HARD HIT YOU KNOW
OBVIOUSLY IMPERIAL COUNTY-
WHICH WAS STRUGGLING BEFORE GOT
HIT HIT VERY HARD TO.
UNDERSTAND JOAQUIN VALLEY- IN
TERMS OF FOOD PROCESSORS- WHO
WERE SELLING PREDOMINATELY TO
RESTAURANTS I HAD AN ISSUE IN
IN- IN IN SALES AND TRY TO MOVE
THEMSELVES FORWARD. I THINK IF
YOU WERE IN THE COMMERCIAL
AVIATION BUSINESS- IN SELLING
CALIFORNIA- YOU WERE HARD HIT
B. BECAUSE OF THOSE SEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN MAX AND PEOPLE ARE
FLYING SOLO- AIRLINES AREN'T
BUYING EQUIPMENT- BUT I THINK
THERE ARE THERE ARE SUMMER IS A
DIRECT RESULT IN WELL I MEAN IF
YOU LOOK AT HOME IMPROVEMENT
JOHN MANUFACTURERS YOU CAN LOOK
AT PEOPLE WHO MAKE EXERCISE
EQUIPMENT YOU LOOK AT PEOPLE
WHO. RIDE BICYCLES- YOU LOOK AT
THAT FOOD PROCESSORS ARE
SELLING TO THE BOX STORES
THEY'RE DOING EXTREMELY WELL SO
YOU KNOW THE INTERESTING THING
IS THAT. MORE THAN GEOGRAPHY IT
WAS THE IMPACT OF COLD IT
REALLY WAS YOUR INDUSTRY SECTOR
YEAR WHEN AND WHO IS YOUR
CUSTOMER WAS. AND I THINK THAT
THAT KIND OF DETERMINED HOW
DEEP THE IMPACT WAS LIKE I
MENTIONED EARLIER IF YOU WERE
SELLING IF YOU WERE AND
AEROSPACE DEFENSE. IF YOU'RE
THE DEFENSE SIDE YOU PROBABLY
DO OKAY- DEFENSE THEIR DEFENSE-
MONEY CONTINUE TO FLOW IN FACT
THE- NO I'M INCREASE THAT- TAKE
MAKE SURE THEIR SUPPLY CHAIN
REMAINED RESILIENT AND INTACT.
IF YOU WERE SELLING TO BOEING
OR AIRBUS OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT YOU YOU WERE PROBABLY YOU
PROBABLY HAD A FIFTY SIXTY
SEVEN PERCENT. A. REDUCTION IN
YOUR IN YOUR IN YOUR BUSINESS.
SO WILL RECEIVE THE IN CERTAIN
REGIONS THE AMP. THAT WAS
GREATEST SEE AN CERTAINLY- INTO
THAT- CONTINUE TO- DURING THIS
TIME. THAT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
FOR. US TO KNOW THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND FOR DEANA- DOWN AT
SERAFINO. COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. HAVE YOU SEEN A
DIFFERENCE IN- THE- CREATING
THE ACCESS TO SKILLED WORKER IN
THE IN THE DEMAND IN IN THAT
CERTAIN AREA ITSELF. YES
ACTUALLY WE HAVE ON THE DEMAND
ACTUALLY WENT DOWN. IT IS OF
STATE TO CONCERNS ONCE WE WERE
ABLE TO SWITCH EVERYTHING OVER
TO A VIRTUAL FORMAT WE ARE ABLE
TO BEGIN TRAINING AGAIN- I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO SEE
HYBRIDS WE GO OUT OF. THIS
PANDEMIC. UP THERE THOUGH THE
GREAT THING ABOUT THE VIRTUAL
AS WE WERE ABLE TO- TRAIN LOCAL
BUSINESSES AT THE SAME TIME.
BUT THERE HAS BEEN AN INCREASED
INTEREST IN GOING BACK TO IN
PERSON AND SO. THE FIRST AT
pWE WERE STAYING SAFE IN THE
PANDEMIC AND THEN AND THEN
TRANSFERRING EVERYTHING OVER TO
A VIRTUAL FORMAT. WE HAD TO
FIGURE ALL THAT OUT THEN WE HAD
A TRAINER TRAINERS ON HOW TO DO
THAT. SO ONCE WE GOT THERE WE
WERE ABLE TO DO THAT. BUT I
WILL SAY IN ADDITION TO CERTAIN
INDUSTRIES- DISTRIBUTION
INDUSTRY HAS HAS NOT STOPPED
THEY HAVE BEEN HIRING.
CONSTANTLY SINCE EVERYTHING ON
A PHYSICAL OFFERING. CAME TO A
HALT. PEOPLE WERE BUYING ONLINE
AND THE DISTRICT OF GOOD STILL.
I CAN. SO WE WERE STILL ABLE TO
TRAIN ANY PEOPLE AND GET THEM
STILL EMPLOYED IN THE
DISTRIBUTION. SECTOR SO THE
DISTRIBUTION SECTOR- IN SAMBAR
DINO CONTINUES TO BE A DEMAND
FOR SKILLED WORKERS THAT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS WORKING
WITH THE BISQUE MADE TO
PERFORM. AND GET THOSE SKILLED
WORKERS ON TO THOSE
DISTRIBUTION PLANTS. ABSOLUTELY
YES ARE I PRIMARY SECTORS OUR
MANUFACTURING AND DISTRIBUTION
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST ONE
MORE QUESTION- FOR BIANCA- YOU
TALKED ABOUT. LOOKING AT LONG
TERM THE LONG TERM PLANNING-
AND NOW WITH- HOW WE'VE BEEN
IMPACTED WITH CLOVER GOING ON A
YEAR- BUT KNOWING THAT OTHER
THINGS COULD COME UP DOWN THE
ROAD. IN THE LONG TERM
STRATEGIC PLANNING IS NOW A
COMPONENT BEING INCLUDED IN
THAT TO ADDRESS PANDEMICS ARE
CERTAIN CRISIS THAT BUSINESSES
COULD BE IMPACTED BY. THAT WAS
FOR BIANCA SURE SORRY I WAS ON
MUTE- YEAH AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER
I'M- TIRED HIGHER SIX OVERHEAD-
WE CONDUCTED THIRD PARTY
INDEPENDENT POLLING AND
RESEARCH OF SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS NATIONWIDE AND IN
CALIFORNIA. AND SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS HAVE SAID 91% OF SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS HAVE SET ACCESS
TO CAPITAL WAS A PROBLEM THEN.
I WE KNOW THAT THESE ISSUES
HAVE ONLY BEEN EXACERBATED BY
CLOSE IN NINETEEN. ON OR AT THE
REASONS BY DR FARLEY AND
AREN'T. OUR SURVEY RESULTS OF
THE ALSO YOU KNOW ON ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE- I SPOKE TO A BUSINESS
OWNER I SPLIT MY TIME DOING
POLICY WORK IN SPEAKING TO
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS DIRECTLY.
A BUSINESS OWNER I SPOKE TO-
JUST THE OTHER WEEK- NEED
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
LAST YEAR. SHE SPENT TWELVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND THAT ON
HEALTH CARE FOR HERSELF AND FOR
HER DAUGHTER. I'M SO I THINK
CONTINUING TO LOOK AT SOME OF
THESE LONG TERM ISSUES THAT
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE BOY ROUGHLY
HALF OF AMERICA'S PRIVATE
SECTOR WORKERS AND HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S WORKERS. ON THESE
KINDS OF ISSUES ARE RATING
RETIREMENT SAVINGS HAS BEEN
SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN HEARING
FROM SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS THAT
THEY'RE DOING. I TO GET BY
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO THE CAPITAL THAT THEY NEED
AT AFFORDABLE PRICES- SO I
THINK THAT THESE ARE SOME OF
THE COMMERCIAL RENT ISSUES
THESE ARE SOME OF. THE LONG
TERM ISSUES THAT BUSINESS
OWNERS ARE GOING TO FACE. EVEN
AFTER NINETEEN. AND JUST TO
FOLLOW. WITH LONG TERM- AND
LOOKING AT SOME IS. RIGHT RE
LAW FROM WHAT IT NOW WITH. IN
AND WE'RE HEADED. IS PART OF
OUR COULD PART OF A COMPONENT
BE. ADEQUATE PLANNING THROUGH
INSURANCE THROUGH DIFFERENT
OTHER COMPONENTS THAT WOULD
HELP BUSINESSES SMALL BUSINESS
IN PARTICULAR. TO CONTINUE TO
WEATHER THE STORM. SURE I'M NOT
AN INSURANCE EXPERT BUT IN
SPEAKING TO SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS AND WORKING ON SOME WITH
COMMISSIONER LARA YOU KNOW WE
HAVE. FOR IT AT AND BUSINESS
OWNERS HAVE BEEN RUNNING INTO
MANY ISSUES AND ARE FINDING AN
INSURANCE THAT WOULD CARRY THEM
THROUGH. A PANDEMIC LIKE THIS
AGAIN I MEAN I THINK THAT ON
THE LONG TERM ACCESS TO CAPITAL
NEEDS THAT SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS ARE FACING BEFORE COVE
IN NINETEEN. WOULD ENABLE THEM
TO WEATHER- A CRISIS LIKE THIS
IF HEAVEN FORBID IT WERE TO
HAPPEN AGAIN. ON THE OTHER.
ECONOMIC CRISES AS WELL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRS
THANK YOU TO THE- PANELISTS FOR
THEIR TIME IN BRINGING THIS
MUCH. NEEDED VITAL INFORMATION
TO THIS COMMITTEE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU I LET ME
GO AHEAD AND TURN TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PARTY PETRI NORRIS WHO'S
ON THE LINE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND THANK YOU ALL OF US
THINK THINK ALL OF YOU FOR
JOINING US TODAY FOR THIS.
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION AND- YEAH I THINK
IT'S SAD IT'S IS MISTER WATSON
YOU ALLUDED TO CALIFORNIA'S. I
CHALLENGES WITH RESPECT TO OUR
SKILLS GAP PRECEDED THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC WE'D ALREADY
SEEN CALIFORNIA'S JOB GROWTH
STARTED TO SLOW. BUT FOR THE
PANDEMIC NOT BECAUSE COMPANIES
WEREN'T HIRING BUT BECAUSE
THERE'S A MISMATCH. OF SKILLS
WITH OUR LABOR FORCE AND ARE
INCREASINGLY TECHNOLOGY DRIVEN
ECONOMY SO THIS IS INCREDIBLY
TIMELY. TOPIC I THINK AS WE
TALK ABOUT THE WORK THAT WE
NEED TO DO Q. REBUILD
CALIFORNIANS THAT. CENTER
ECONOMY AND- RECOVERY- YOU ALL
GAVE ACTUALLY SOME REALLY
PRACTICAL AND TANGIBLE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR WHAT WE CAN
DO TO. ACCELERATE CALIFORNIANS
ARE INVESTMENTS IN IN WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND IT'S GOING TO
ASK A COUPLE OF FOLLOW UPS ON.
ON TODAY'S STUDENT MISTER
WATSON. I YOU TALK ABOUT. THE
NEED IN YOUR TO AND- ARE IN. IN
THE- PANEL PROGRAM CAN YOU JUST
SPEAK A LITTLE BIT TO. HELP US
UNDERSTAND WHAT THAT WOULD LOOK
LIKE- IF THAT IF WE ARE AND
CONSTRAINS WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO SEE CALIFORNIA DO WITH THE
EMPLOYMENT CONNELL TRAINING
PROGRAM. AND WHAT IN YOUR VIEW
WITH THAT WOULD BE THE RESULT
AND ADMIT IT TO SMALL
INVESTMENTS. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION THAT THAT IS THAT IS A
GREAT QUESTION BECAUSE YOU KNOW
WE ARE A MULTI EMPLOYER
CONTRACT WITH THE G. P. AND- IN
PREVIOUS YEARS ACTUALLY LAST
YEAR. WELL WE WERE ABLE TO
TRAIN MORE THAN THIRTEEN
HUNDRED. EMPLOYEES IN IN SMALL
MANUFACTURERS USING USING OUR
PLAN TO TRAINING PANEL FUNDS
THE REDUCTION THAT FUND THIS
YEAR WE WILL TRAIN ONLY FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY. OF
EMPLOYEES IN SMALL BUSINESSES
AND SMALL MANUFACTURERS SO.
IT'S JUST IT AS WE GET MORE
MONEY INTO THE EMPLOYMENT
AROUND INCOME FOR WORKERS
SORRY. SORRY YES GOT CARRY ON
YEAH SO ARE WE DOING GLOBAL
WORKER TRAINING SO WE'RE WE'RE
WORKING WITHIN THE ORGANIZATION
ITSELF TO UP SKILL THEIR WORK
FORCE TO DO A COUPLE THINGS
FIRST OF ALL GET INVOLVED IN
NEW TECHNOLOGIES ARE GETTING
INVOLVED IN MAKING MORE MONEY-
AND THAT YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
SIMPLY- MITIGATING- YOU KNOW
THE HIRING THAT THESE
MANUFACTURERS CAN'T FINE. SO
THE MORE MONEY THE MORE MONEY
THAT EMPLOYMENT TRAINING AND
PANEL HAS- IT'LL MAKE IT IT'LL
MAKE AN INCREASE IN WAGES IN IN
FACT I THINK DISCOUNT STATE
UNIVERSITY NORTHRIDGE STUDY
THAT WAS OUT ON THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANEL INDICATED THAT
OVER TIME AFTER TRAINING
THERE'S A THREE THOUSAND DOLLAR
INCREASING IN WAGE FOR THOSE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN TRAINED-
AND I THINK THE OTHER THING IS
THAT WITH WE NEED TO TRAIN AS
MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE
WITH THIS WORK FOR SHORTAGE AND
THE NEED TO ADOPT TECHNOLOGY
WE'RE JUST NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
FIND THOSE FOLKS OFF THE STREET
RIGHT NOW- FOR A NUMBER OF
REASONS FIRST OF ALL WE'RE ALL
WORKING FROM HOME- YOU KNOW
IT'S VERY HARD TO. FIND
CANDIDATES RIGHT NOW I MEAN WE
DO A LOT OF WORK IN OUR COMPANY
TO TRY AND RECRUIT FOR
MANUFACTURERS. I'LL TELL YOU
IT'S VERY VERY DIFFICULT TO-
PLAYING FIELD WORKERS RIGHT NOW.
YEAH ISSUE IS WITH NEW- WITH
THE NEWLY SKILL IN NEWLY
TRAINED- COMING OF COMMUNITY.
THEY LIVE HAVE TO WORK IN THE
CAN. IN WHICH THEY RESIDE THEY
THEY REALLY CAN'T GO ANY PLACE
ALL STATE. BECAUSE OF FOR A
BUILDING HOUSING IF THEY CAN'T
FIND A JOB WITHIN. FIVE OR SIX
OR TEN MILES OF THEIR OF THEIR-
WHERE THEY RATE YOU KNOW FROM
IF THEY WERE DAHLE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE OR ANOTHER COMMUNICATOR
STAFF TO WORK IN THAT
COMMUNITY. AND SO THAT LIMITS
THE AMOUNT OF THE NEW WORKERS
COMING OUT OF. OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES TO BE
ABLE TO- BE ABLE TO MIGRATE TO
OTHER COMMUNITIES TO BE ABLE TO
WORK. IT'S REALLY IT'S REALLY
JUST WORKFORCE ISSUE IS REALLY
GOING TO BE A PROBLEM FOR
MANUFACTURING MOVING DOWN THE
LINE BECAUSE- WE'RE NOT A
SKILLED WORKER WE'RE NOT GONNA
BE ABLE TO ADOPT TECHNOLOGIES
WITHOUT TECHNOLOGIES BUT I CAN
BE COMPETITIVE. NO WE'RE NOT
COMPETITIVE WE'RE GOING TO LOSE.
MANY FACTORS IN THE- I COULD
NOT AGREE. WITH YOU MORE I
THINK IT IS A KEY. HUGE AND-
PRIORITY OTHERS AND I THINK A
BI RECOVERY AS WE- AT. IN THE
TWO YEARS EVEN TAKE. TECH AND
ISN'T. CRIPPLE I YOU MIGHT HAVE
HAD SOMETHING TO ON ON TO WHAT
WAS RIGHT TO SAID. I'M
SPECIFICALLY YOU YOU IT MEANT.
I THINK YOU'RE NUMBER ONE KIND
OF LIKE. A PRIORITY WAS FOR
ASKING. OUR INVESTMENT. OR TO
ACTUALLY START INVESTMENT IN
CONTRACT EDUCATION. AGAIN CAN
YOU. JUST CAN YOU HELP US OUT-
FOR US AND- IN TERMS OF WHAT
THAT WOULD DELIVER FOR. AFRICA
FOR I'M IN. MY CAR. IN IN YOUR
VIEW LIKE WE IS THAT YOUR
NUMBER PRIORITY. ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU ON A NURSE FIRST AT
EVEN THAT QUESTION EVERY
APPRECIATE THAT FIRST OF ALL I
WANT TO DO. YOU KNOW TO
UNDERSTAND THERE IS NO
INVESTMENT INTO CONTRACT
EDUCATION OUR NUMBER ONE
FUNDING SOURCE THAT WE USE
RIGHT NOW IS THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANEL. AND AS AS WAS
PRIOR SAID WITH THE DECREASE IN
HATE OUR WITH THE DECREASE IN
MONEY COMING TO THAT THAT DOES
AFFECT ALL OF THE TRAINING
ORGANIZATIONS THAT DO NORMALLY
RELY ON ETP IN ORDER TO PROVIDE.
THAT TRAINING. AND BY INVESTING
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE PLATE BY
BEGINNING THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM ON THAT WHAT THAT DOES
IS THAT IT ENABLES THE LARGEST.
OUR CONTRACT EDUCATION SYSTEM
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
TO BE ABLE TO TRAIN PEOPLE AT A
GREAT PRICE RIGHT NOW.
ACCORDING TO THE WORLD ECONOMIC
ON ECONOMIC FORUM. BY TWENTY
TWENTY TO NO LESS THAN 54% OF
ALL EMPLOYEES WILL BRING YOU
REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT RE SKILLING
AND UP SKILLING. AND IN COURT
ACCORDING TO PEW RESEARCH 87%
OF WORKERS BELIEVE THAT IT WILL
BE ESSENTIAL TO GET TRAINING
AND DEVELOP NEW SKILLS
THROUGHOUT THEIR WORK LIFE IN
ORDER TO KEEP UP WITH THE
CHANGES IN THEIR WORK FACED.
THAT'S JUST TO STAY COMPETITIVE
THIS IS TO KEEP THEIR
BUSINESSES COMPETITIVE
BUSINESSES ALREADY HAVE A SKILL
ISSUE AS WITH A SEDATED BEFORE.
IF WE DON'T UPSKILL THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND GIVEN THE
SKILLS THAT THEY WANT THEY WILL
FIND THEIR THAT THEY WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO STATE- COMPETITIVE
IN WHAT THEY'RE DOING. AND
THEY'LL END UP LOSING THEIR
JOBS. ALSO THIS ALSO GIVES
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE FOR
ADVANCEMENT WAGE INCREASE IN
ITS WHICH OPENS UP THOSE
FRONTLINE POSITIONS WHICH WE
CAN THEN. BACK FILL WITH
INDIVIDUALS THAT NEED TRAINING
TO GET TO WORK MANY INDIVIDUALS
CAN'T WAIT TWO YEARS TO GET A
DEGREE OR FOUR YEARS OR SIX
YEARS TO GET. EMPLOYMENT THEY
NEED TO HAVE EMPLOYMENT NOW AND
THEN THEY CAN TAKE SCHOOLING
WHILE THEY'RE EMPLOYED. BUT
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO WORKING
OUT AND NOT AT A MINIMUM WAGE
JOB THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
WORK AT A LIVING WAGE JOB.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ACROSS THE-
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS THE
ACCESS TO REACH THEIR
COMMUNITIES THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. ALL ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND IT
WOULD HELP OUT UNDER TRAINING
AGENCIES SUCH AS THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANEL WE WORK IN
TANDEM WITH THAT SUCH AS WITH
THE EMPTY SEAT AND WE WORK WITH
MANY SECTORS THE- ONE OF THE
WEAKNESSES OF THE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING PANELS THERE'S VERY
SPECIFIC SECTORS THAT YOU CAN
WORK IN AND YOU CAN PROVIDE
TRAINING AND BY WORKING WITH
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
YOU WE CAN WORK WITH ALL
EMPLOYERS WHO ARE NEEDING TO UP
SKILL AND RE SKILL THEIR
EMPLOYEES. AND NEED TO HIRE FOR
THEIR SHORT REALLY OPENS UP
THAT SCALE AND- AND WE STILL
HAVE THE SAME METRICS THAT WE
WORK IN THE SAME ETHICS THAT WE
WORK ON. THANK YOU FOR THAT
THANK YOU I DO I THINK THAT'S
OF A SUPER EXCITING OPPORTUNITY
AND JUST WENT ONE LAST QUESTION
IF I NAY MADAM CHAIR I'M- IT IS
IT'S A LITTLE BIT SIMILAR MAYBE
TO THE QUESTION I ASKED OF OUR-
EARLIER PANELISTS BIT ODD.
CALIFORNIA'S WORKFORCE
CHALLENGES ARE CERTAINLY NOT
GOING TO BE UNIQUE YOU NEED FOR
CALIFORNIA AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THAT THAT THAT
WERE FACING ACROSS THE NATION
AND INDEED ACROSS THE WORLD. SO
ARE THERE OTHER STATES THAT ARE
ARE DOING A REALLY GOOD JOB AT
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT OR DOING
A REALLY GOOD JOB AT UPSKILLING
RETRAINING. OUR WORKERS AND
PREPARING THEM FOR THE JOBS OF
TOMORROW. IS THERE ANYWAY WE
CAN LOOK TO DO IT AS A MODEL.
NOT FOR ANY ANY OF THE
PANELISTS WHO HAVE A FEW. RIGHT
I THINK THERE ARE FEW STATES-
FIRST OF ALL CALIFORNIA WITH
EMPLOYMENT TRAINING PANEL DOES
SET THE STANDARD IN MANY CASES
FOR OTHER STATES THERE ARE VERY
MANY OTHER STATES THAT DON'T
HAPPEN. THIS FORM OF- OF- OF
THE WORK FORCE- SUBJECT OF
BIRDS ARE SUBSIDIZATION OF THE.
I CAN SEE THAT BIG. WILD STATES
IN WHICH THEY RESIDE AND OPEN.
MUCH LATER ADVANTAGE OF
TRAINING AND THEY CAN'T ANOTHER
STATE IN WHICH THEY ARE
POSSIBLY TEXAS OR ARIZONA OR
SOMETHING ELSE. IN TERMS OF
THOSE STATES THAT ACTUALLY
HAVE- YOU KNOW GOOD GOOD
PROGRAMS I THINK NEW JERSEY
PROBABLY HAS A GOOD ONE AS I AS
I REMEMBER. IN IN LOOKING AT
SOME OF THIS- THEY THEY DO A
NICE JOB BECAUSE THEY DO A
TERRIFIC JOB OF CONNECTING- THE
EDUCATIONAL- OF YOU KNOW LIKE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND
UNIVERSITIES TO INDUSTRY ANY
ANY OF ANY ORGANIZATION THAT
CAN DO THAT- IS REALLY DOING A
GOOD JOB AND THEN I THINK NEW
JERSEY ALSO SUPPORTS IT WAS
SOME KIND OF FUNDING. IN TERMS
OF APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE BECAUSE
THIS IS THIS IS. THIS IS A
MULTIPLE TYPE PROGRAM NOT ONLY
DO NEW DGP- NOT ONLY DO DENTURE
TECHNICAL COURAGE OCCASION YOU
NEED AN APPRENTICE PROGRAM AS
WELL IN WHICH WE CAN PROVIDE
INCENTIVES FOR MANUFACTURERS TO
BRING IN. YOUNGER HIGHLY
SKILLED WORKERS TO LEARN ABOUT
MANUFACTURING IN IN OU KNOW
GETTING TRAINED IN THE CULTURE
OF MANUFACTURING. AND BE ABLE
TO BE THE NEXT GENERATION OF
THE WORKERS IT'S GOING TO TAKE
US. TAKE OUR WHOLE
MANUFACTURING COMMUNITY. INTO
THE FUTURE SO. THAT'S A LONG
ANSWER BUT I HAVE TO SAY THAT
CALIFORNIA WITH ITS IMPORTANT
TRAINING PANEL IS KIND OF A-
LOT. YOU DO. HAVE TYPES OF.
THAT THEY THAT GREAT NOT AT A
TRAINING ADVANTAGE FOR A WORKER
BUT ALSO. FOR WORKERS IS.
MISTER INTEREST IN THE
INTERESTED AND WHEN HE GOT AND
TURN IT OVER. TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OR HER AND THEN I COME
FROM WITH ONE QUESTION. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND I'LL TRY TO
MAKE THIS CHRIS QUICK- YOU KNOW
ONE OF THE THINGS KNOW THE
PENDING. AND IS THAT IT REALLY
HIGHLIGHTED THE NEGATIVE
IMPACTS OF LONG- SUPPLY CHAINS
FOR OUR MANUFACTURING SECTOR.
SO WE KNOW THAT WE NEED TO HAVE
MORE ON SHORING OF
MANUFACTURING. AND WE KNOW WE
HAVE AN AND NOT ONLY HAVE I
HAVE. IS THERE MORE TO DO
BEFORE THAT. TO CREATE THE
SKILLED WORKERS WORK FORCE FOR
MANUFACTURING. BUT WE ALSO NOW
HAVE A LARGE SECTOR OF.
UNEMPLOYED FROM HOSPITALITY
FROM RETAIL FROM RESTAURANTS.
SO MY QUESTION AND IT GOES BACK
TO MISTER WATSON WHAT YOU WERE
SAYING IS WE NEED TO BE BETTER
AT BRIDGING. THAT THE JOB SKILL
NEEDS AND THE TRAINING THAT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES OR OUR OTHER
PROGRAMS CAN PROVIDE. IT IF YOU
COULD GIVE ME YOU IT MAYBE-
MISS- CRAVEABLE CAN GIVE US.
THE TOP THREE THINGS THE
LEGISLATURE CAN DO TO BRIDGE
THOSE PROGRAMS ARE NOT ONLY DO
WE COME UP TO. A GOOD LEVEL BUT
WERE ABLE TO INCREASE AND
ABSORB SOME OF THAT AND IT
TREAT RETRAIN SOME OF THOSE
UNEMPLOYED WORKERS. THE TOP ONE
TWO THREE THINGS WE SHOULD DO.
GO WELL I THINK FIRST NEWS IS
AFTER IS TO PROVIDE FUNDING
FOR- INCOME TRAINING AND FOR-
APPRENTICE TRAINING WOULD BE
WOULD BE TO TALK TO FOR ME- I
THINK I THINK THOSE ARE THE
AREAS THAT I THINK WE CAN IN
TERMS OF CITIES IN
MANUFACTURING WE CAN CERTAINLY-
BUT A LOT OF. STUDENTS IN THOSE
TWO AREAS. IF WE HAD THE
FUNDING AND IF WE COULD GO OUT
AND WORK WITH MANUFACTURERS TO
BE ABLE O- TAKE NEW WORKERS
OUT OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES. AND EXTREME
AFTER. WE GET WE NEED TO GET
THIS BRIDGE AND THEN FROM THERE
I KNOW I CAN'T SPEAK FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SIGN ON. HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE THE
RETRAINING- THEIR STUDENTS BUT
I KNOW MOST OF TWO STUDENTS
TRAINED IN MANUFACTURING. WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO GET THEM OUT
INTO THE. MANUFACTURING
COMMUNITY AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. I WOULD LIKE TO- ADD
ON. ON TO THAT THAT.
MANUFACTURES WON'T COME BACK
WITHOUT A SKILLED WORKFORCE
STATE THE BILL ONLY COME BACK
IF WE HAVE THAT SKILLED
WORKFORCE. SO AGAIN. A GREEN
1100% WITH MISTER WATSON.
SPENDING IS THE NUMBER ONE WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO. TRAIN THESE
INDIVIDUALS. AND PUT THEM TO
WORK WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
CONVINCE MANUFACTURERS THAT WE
HAVE A SKILLED. WORKFORCE THE-
THE OTHER IS ACCESS TO SOFTWARE.
THERE'S MANY GREAT SOFTWARE.
PLATFORMS THAT ARE OUT THERE
THAT WE CAN USE AGAIN FUNDING
TO GET ACCESS TO THOSE TAX
SOFTWARE. PLATFORMS THAT WE CAN
WORK IN A HYBRID WORLD OR
VIRTUAL WORLDS WHICH EVER ONE
REGARDLESS OF HOW YOU LOOK AT
IT. AT LATIMES SOFTWARE HELPS
US TO BECOME SAFETY BEFORE WE
DO ACTUAL HANDS ON ACTIVITIES.
AND THEN I WOULD SAY ONE OTHER
ASPECT THAT WE HAVEN'T REALLY
TALKED ABOUT HERE AND I WOULD
SAY THE THIRD ONE WOULD BE.
BUSINESS IS ACCEPTING JUSTICE
INVOLVED INDIVIDUALS
BACKGROUNDS. ON IT IS IMPORTANT
FOR BUSINESSES TO BE OPEN TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
BACKGROUNDS IF WE'RE TRYING TO
SUCCESSFULLY REINTEGRATE THEM
INTO BACK INTO SOCIETY. THEY
NEED TO BE ABLE TO WORK AND IF
THE MORE BUSINESSES THAT TELLEM
NOW NOT ONLY CONTINUES TO PUT
THEM INTO ONE DIRECTION AND
THAT IS TO BACK TO RESET UPDATE
AND GO BACK TO PRISON. WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WEAK IN Q.
INCLUDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
JUSTICE AND BACH WE INVEST IN
TO UP SKILLING AND RE SKILLING
ARE INDIVIDUALS AND ASK MR
WATSON ALSO SAID. COME UP WITH
SOME SORT OF APPRENTICESHIP OR
PATHWAY THAT HELPS INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE GETTING TRAINED IN
MANUFACTURING ARE GETTING
TRAINED IN DISTRIBUTION HAVE A
PATHWAY DIRECTLY INTO THOSE
INDUSTRIES THAT'S ONE OF THE
ISSUES WE HAD WE DIDN'T HAVE
ANY. EMPLOYMENT BRIDGE PROGRAM
THAT WE DID WORK WITH A
SPECIFIC WE WORK WITH SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY. AND
THEY HAD OUR COLLEGE- STUDENTS
GO THROUGH A SPECIFIC PROGRAM
ON LEARNING HOW TO WORK ON A
NEED. BECAUSE THEY LEARNED HOW
TO WORK ON DIFFERENT EQUIPMENT
AT COLLEGE BUT THEY NEVER
LEARNED HOW TO WORK ON A METER
CHAU CONTRACT EDUCATION CAME IN
TO BRIDGE THAT GAP WE TOOK
THESE COLLEGE STUDENTS WERE
GIVEN THE METER. AND THEY WERE
ABLE TO GO OUT AND. GET AN
ACTUAL JOB WITH SOUTHERN CAL
CORNIA GAS COMPANY SO TEMPLE.-THAT AS WE LOOK AT THE PRO. D.
THE IN. IS IN WITH THE TRAIN
THAT WE'RE DESIGNING AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT CONTRACT EDUCATE
EDUCATION IS VERY GOOD AT. CMT
C. IS A WONDERFUL PARTNER WITH
WITH THE CONTRACT EDUCATION
UNITS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THEY WORK
SPECIFICALLY WITH
MANUFACTURING. THEY ALSO WORK
ON LINE- IDENTIFYING THOSE
DIFFERENT NEEDS WE WORK IN
TANDEM WITH ONE ANOTHER ON
THEIR- MULTIPLE EMPLOYER
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMME. THESE
ARE SOME ISSUES THAT DATA
STATEWIDE WE SEE AND IF WE CAN
NUMBER ONE FUNDING NUMBER TO
FUNDING IN NUMBER THREE
FUNDING. IF WE HAVE THE
SPENDING ASPECTS WE CAN
ACTUALLY MAKE A DIFFERENCE WITH
THE SKILLED WORKFORCE THAT THAT
CALIFORNIA NEEDS. OUR CRIME LET
ME LET ME JUST JUMP IN HERE TOO
AND THIS SEGMENT OF THE AGENDA
I MISSED ONE QUESTION DO YOU
HAVE ANY WORDS OF ADVICE TO
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS TRYING TO
SERVE SMALL BUSINESSES DURING
THE PANDEMIC. I MEAN I WOULDN'T
PRESUME TO GIVE UNSOLICITED
ADVICE PARTNERS BUT IF I AND I
THINK THAT WHAT HAS BEEN
DEMONSTRATED BY THE PANELISTS
TODAY- IS REALLY AND
DEMONSTRATIVE OF WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN DOING ESPECIALLY SINCE
BECAUSE THE NINETEEN BUT BEFORE
AND THAT IS WORKING TOGETHER
AND PARTNERING. BECAUSE WE
SIMPLY CANNOT BE EXPERTS IN
EVERYTHING FOR EVERYONE SO YOU
KNOW STAYING IN YOUR LANE AND
FINDING THOSE EXPERTS LIKE THE
MANUFACTURERS- THE FOLKS WHO
WORK IN WORKFORCE- OUR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROVIDERS
THE SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTERS WHO CAN HELP BRIDGE
THAT DIGITAL DIVIDE- HELP SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS WHO MIGHT NOT.
BE ABLE TO ACCESS THE TPP
LONER. NOW HAD- I THINK
PARTNERING IS PROBABLY THE
NUMBER ONE THING AND MAKING
SURE THAT FOLKS CONTINUE TO DO
THAT AND THINK CREATIVELY IN
THOSE PARTNERSHIPS IS. SUPER
IMPORTANT. THANK YOU THINK EACH
OF OUR PANELISTS FOR JOINING US
I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON
TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION
OF TODAY'S HEARING ARE FOR
PEOPLE DIALING IN TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY WE ARE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE THE
CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS. 877-692-8957 THE ACCESS
CODE IS ONE THREE ONE OF FIVE
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO YOU CAN ALSO
FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY JOBS COMMITTEE WEBSITE
OR ON YOUR TV SCREEN. WHEN YOU
CALL IN THE OPERATOR ON THE
LINE WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW TO BE PLACED IN THE
QUEUE IF YOU'RE COLLEEN IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ANY BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTANE ARE
YOUR LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND
YOUR SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE
THE SOUND DISTORTION AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER IF YOU HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS I WITH ARE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT
916-319-2090 ENTER COMMITTEE
SECRETARY MERCEDES WILL BE
THERE TO HELP. WE WILL ALSO BE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN COMMENTS TO
THE COMMITTEE UNTIL MARCH
FIFTEENTH. I WOULD REQUEST THAT
EACH PUBLIC COMMENT BE LIMITED
TO THREE MINUTES I ANY EXTENDED
COMMON SHOULD BE PROVIDED IN
WRITING. IF THE OPERATOR WOULD
LIKE TO BEGIN WORKING THROUGH
THE CALLERS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND ALSO IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT ON TODAY'S CALL YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOUR LINE NUMBER WHEN YOU'RE
LINE NUMBER IS CALLED PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME FOR THE RECORD
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU DO HAVE A
COMMENT ON THE CALL PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. MY
FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM NINE
THIRTY SIX. ONE THIRTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS-
THIS IS ALL LOWER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING NEARLY
A QUARTER MILLION CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES IN BOTH K.
TWELVE AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
WE APPRECIATE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
PROVIDES A ONE HALF PERCENT
COLECTIVA DE STUDENTS
BENEFITING FORMULA WE HOWEVER
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
COALITION BE CONDITION ON
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS. WE
ALSO URGE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR PROVIDE
FIFTEEN COMPOUNDED THREE POINT
84% COLLECTION COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO BE CONSISTENT WITH
THE COLA DAY IS. PROPOSED FOR
K. TWELVE. WE ALSO URGE
CONSIDERING AMOUNT OF. DO BY
FOR CLASS PROVIDE. AND MUCH OF
THE- DEVELOPMENT FUNDING IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS GEARED
TOWARDS TEACHERS AND FACULTY
AND OUR CLASS BY PROFESSIONALS
ALSO PROVIDE SUPPORT WITH. IT
AND FINING AND DESERVE TO
RECEIVE TRAINING ON THE LATEST
DEVELOPMENTS AND BEST PRACTICES
IN THE FIELD AS WELL. THANK YOU.
ONE NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CARE CERVANTES AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS LUCY SALCEDO CARTER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF NONPROFIT WE'RE POLICY
ALLIANCE OF MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND ORGANIZATIONS AND THE
VOICE OF THE NONPROFIT SECTOR
IN CALIFORNIA. THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR IS THE FOURTH LARGEST
EMPLOYER BY INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA. AND BRING IN MORE
THAN FOUR FORTY BILLION DOLLARS
AND OUT OF STATE FUNDS TO THE
STATE ECONOMY EVERY YEAR.
NONPROFITS GENERATE 15% OF THE
GROSS STATE PRODUCT. NONPROFITS
ARE KEY EMPLOYERS AND KEY
ECONOMIC DRIVERS AS WELL AS
CRITICAL SERVICE PROVIDERS.
NONPROFITS PROVIDE FOR EXAMPLE
32% OF ALL MEDICARE SERVICES.
CALIFORNIA NONPROFITS HAVE ALSO
BEEN DEEPLY AFFECTED BY THE
PANDEMIC AND ECONOMIC DOWNTURN
WHICH NATIONWIDE IN THE PAST
YEAR THE SECTOR HAS LOST NINE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THOUSAND JOBS
AND JOB LOSSES CONTINUE. WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT NONPROFITS ARE
INCLUDED IN THE CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESS CODE NINETEEN
RELIEF GRANT PROGRAM WE HAVE
SERVED AS AN APPLICATION
PARTNER IN THE FIRST TWO ROUNDS
HELPING THOUSANDS OF NONPROFITS
NAVIGATE THE APPLICATION
PROCESS. WE ALSO GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE ADDITIONAL TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN SENATE BILL
EIGHTY SEVEN. UP PROVIDED TO
THE RELIEF PROGRAM AND WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS FOR NONPROFIT
OUTREACH NONPROFIT GRANT T.
DATA. AND THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR CARVE OUT YOUR NONPROFIT
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS. BECAUSE
OF THE NONPROFIT SECTORS VITAL
ROLE IN THE STATE'SECONOMY IN
THE WORK FORCE AND THE SERVICES
SUPPLY CHAIN WE ASK THAT YOU
ENSURE THAT ANY RELIEF PROGRAMS
AND POLICIES FOR NONPROFITS ARE
COMPARABLE. TO THOSE FOR PROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS NONPROFITS ARE
KEY TO A THRIVING ECONOMY AND
THE WELL BEING OF CALIFORNIANS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT ON
TODAY'S CALL VIA THE PHONE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. NINE THIRTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH
MY NAME'S MATT SATIN WITH A
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION AND WE REPRESENT.
COUNTLESS COMMUNITY RESTAURANTS
INDEPENDENT RESTAURANTS
THROUGHOUT YOUR DISTRICTS AND I
JUST WANNA THANK YOU FOR HAVING
THE HEARING AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR FOCUS ON THESE. ISSUES I
THINK AS WE KNOW IN THE MIDST
OF THE- PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS
THAT EMERGE LAST MARCH THE
STATE'S AGGRESSIVE AND
NECESSARY STEPS TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND SAFETY OF
THE STATE'S RESIDENTS.
UNFORTUNATELY THOSE TRADE OFFS
FOR THOSE PROTECTED PUBLIC
HEALTH MEASURES I HAVE HAD A
NEAR DESTINATION IMPACT ON OUR
STREETS RESTAURANT COMMUNITY.
SAID THE RESTAURANT ECONOMIC
CRISIS CONTINUES TO RAPIDLY
TAKE HOLD. WE BELIEVE THE
STATE'S GOT NAVIGATION TO
TAKING EQUALLY AGGRESSIVE STEPS
TO ADDRESS THE ECONOMIC HARM.
AND WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
STEPS HAVE BEEN TAKEN SO FAR
FOR SHORT TERM RELIEF IN THE
GRANT PROGRAMS AND BELIEVE
THEIR GREAT START. AS YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S RESTAURANTS OF THE
CORNERSTONE OF EVERY COMMUNITY
THROUGHOUT YOUR DISTRICTS YOU
SEE MANY OF INDEPENDENT
RESTAURANTS THAT MAKE UP THE
FABRIC OF YOUR COMMUNITY. THE
FOR THE PANDEMIC SHUTDOWNS
THERE OF ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WORKING IN
RESTAURANTS. JUST SINCE MARCH
AN ESTIMATED NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND TO ONE MILLION OF THEM
HAVE EITHER BEEN LAID OFF FOR
ABOUT. RESTAURANT SECTORS
DEFINITELY BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THE STATE'S
NINETY THOUSAND RESTAURANT
LOCATIONS ARE OWNED AND
OPERATED BY INDEPENDENT
PROVIDERS IN YOUR COMMUNITIES.
ADDITIONALLY 60% OF
CALIFORNIANS RESTAURANTS ARE
OWNED BY PEOPLE OF COLOR. WHEN
IT COMES TO REALLY PROGRAMS
INTENDED TO HELP WE ASK YOU TO
CONSIDER A FEW THINGS THAT ARE
UNIQUE TO THE RESTAURANT
COMMUNITY. ONE WE WERE ONE OF
THE LARGEST EMPLOYERS IN THE
STATE SAID WE ARE PEOPLE HAPPY
AND MORE PROUD OF THAT.
RESTAURANT LABOR COSTS ARE
HIGHER THAN ELSEWHERE IN THE
NATION HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AND
WE BELIEVE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANTS BEEN SHUT LONGER
THAN ANY OTHER EMPLOYMENT
SECTOR NATIONWIDE. MY MAIN
POINT HERE IS JUST THAT
RESTAURANTS HAVE HIGH NUMBERS
OF EMPLOYEES. WHICH DOESN'T
NECESSARILY REFLECT BIG
BUSINESS VERSUS SMALL BUSINESS.
AS RESTAURANTS WITH EVEN ONE
TWO OR THREE LOCATIONS CAN
QUICKLY ADD UP TO LOTS OF
EMPLOYEES. SINCE THE PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAMS BEEN CITED
HERE A FEW TIMES IN THIS
HEARING I WANTED TO JUST POINT
OUT A FEW THINGS. CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANTS RECEIVED P. P.
LOANS THAT EXCEEDED THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE LOAN SIZE OF A
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR TWO REASONS. ONE LOAN
AMOUNTS ARE BASED ON LABOR
COSTS WHICH TYPICALLY ACCOUNT
FOR MORE THAN HALF OF THE
RESTAURANTS COMES. INTO
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANTS
EXPERIENCED ABOVE AVERAGE
LOSSES GIVEN THE PUBLIC HEALTH
ORDERS THAT HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY
LIMITED. OR IN MOST CASES
PROHIBITED SAID INDOOR DINING
AND MUCH OF THE STATE'S IN
SPOTS MUST MARCH. ONE OF THE
KEY OBJECTIVES OF THAT TV
PROGRAMS TO ENCOURAGE
RECIPIENTS KEEP EMPLOYEES ON
THE PAYROLL. NO ANSWER GIVEN AT
THE RESTAURANT SPENT AT LEAST
60% ON LABOR RESTAURANTS GOT
BIGGER LOANS IN BOCA THAT MONEY
FLOW THROUGH TO WORKERS HAS
INTENDED. SO AGAIN THE NUMBER
OF RESTAURANT EMPLOYEES OR
SIGNS OF A RESTAURANT LOAN DOES
NOT NECESSARILY CORRELATE TO
WHETHER A RESTAURANT IS BIG OR
SMALL OR UNSTABLE ECONOMIC
FOOTING. THE NEST MAJORITY THE
STATE'S RESTAURANT JOBS ARE
INSIDE THE RESTAURANT DINING
ROOMS OF ALL KINDS. THOSE THAT
MENTION REMAIN CLOSED IN THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THE COUNTIES.
SO SOMETHING TO CONSIDER WHEN
THE STATE BEGINS TO AUTHORIZE
COUNTIES TO ALLOW US BACK
INSIDE I JUST REMIND YOU THAT
THE RE OPENING WILL ONLY BE
COUNTY BY COUNTY AND WILL UNDER
THE STATE'S CURRENT TIERED
REOPENING SYSTEM. NOT GET TO A
POINT THAT ALLOWS US TO HAVE
GREATER THAN 50% IN DROUGHT
STRICKEN CITY. AND FOR THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE MOST
KILLINGS WILL BE LUCKY TO GET
AUTHORIZED TO OUT 25% OCCUPANCY
ENDORSE. BUT WE'RE NOT THERE
YET. SO THE RESULT. IS A FORCE
LIMITATION OF OUR OPERATIONS
AND THE BEST ONE DATA 50%
OPERATIONS ALLOWED. YET WILL
STILL HAVE A 100% OF OUR FIX
DAILY COSTS RENTS. INSURANCE
AND OTHER COSTS. AS REACHED
HERE EARLIER ON ONE OF YOUR
PANEL THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
SOME EMPLOYMENT SECTORS HAVE
BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC SHUT
DOWNS. THAN OTHERS AND
RESTAURANTS STAND OUT
UNDOUBTEDLY. SO WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR FOCUS ON THESE
ISSUES AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
FOCUS ON SMALL BUSINESS AND
DEFINITELY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN THE
LEGISLATURE ON THESE THINGS IN
THE FUTURE. THANK YOU. NINE
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ANNE
RAFFERTY AND I AM THE DIRECTOR
IF YOU COLLEGE AND A MEMBER OF
THE BILL CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE COLLABORATIVE
AND I SUPPORT THE NEEDS- MY
COLLEAGUE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
DEANNA KREHBIEL SHARED EARLIER.
AND AND EXAMPLE OF OUR RAPID
RESPONSE AND SCALABILITY AND
THE IS OUR NEWLY DEVELOPED
STATEWIDE UTILITY LINE
CLEARANCE BARBAROUS TRAINING IT
IS A TWO HUNDRED OUR FIVE WEEK
TRAINING SPONSORED INITIALLY
HERE BY P. JEANNIE TO TRAIN
OVER TWO THOUSAND WORKERS. ANY
WORKERS EARN A HIGHER WAGE OF
TWENTY ONE DOLLARS AND SIXTY
THREE CENTS PER HOUR AND LEAD
TO A THIRTY SIX DOLLAR AND FIVE
CENTS PER HOUR BLEACH AND OVER
FIFTEEN OF OUR OF SKILL
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES WILL BE
DELIVERING THIS SKILL TRAINING
TO PERFORM HIGHLY HAZARDOUS
JOB. TO REDUCE VEGETATION
PEELED IN CALIFORNIA AND ON THE
INITIAL RESPONSE WHICH IS
HIGHLY ENCOURAGING AT ONE
COLLEGE WITH OVER THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY TWO APPLICATIONS AND.
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE TRAINING.
THIS PROGRAM IS AN EXAM OF HOW
UPSKILL CALIFORNIA AND OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CONTRACT
EDUCATION UNITS ARE SUPPORTING
SMALL BUSINESSES- BY RETRAINING
WORKFORCE. AND SO WHILE THIS
INITIAL FUNDING SPONSORED BY P.
JEANNIE HAS BEEN INSTRUMENTAL
TO LAUNCH THE PROGRAM AND
DEANNA HAD SHARED ON OUR
SUSTAINABILITY OF A HIGH WAGE
JOB TRAINING SUCH AS THAT. IS
CRITICAL TO ADDRESSING NOT FUEL
REDUCTION AND WORKER TRAINING
CALIFORNIA. I AND SUPPORT OF
THE SMALL BUSINESSES. A
QUESTION EARLIER AROUND HOW
CALIFORNIA AND IN OTHER STATES
ARE PARTICIPATING TOGETHER I
WAS RECENTLY ATTENDING EIGHT U.
S. PRE APPRENTICESHIP MEETING
WITH NORTH CAROLINA TEXAS AND
PENNSYLVANIA REPRESENTATIVE.
AND I FOUND QUICKLY THAT THE
OTHER STATES ARE WATCHING
CALIFORNIA AND THIS PROGRAM AND
PARTICULARLY A CLOSE. THE
CALIFORNIA CAN TAKE THE LEAD
FOR YOU ARE WITH OUR UPSKILL
CALIFORNIA CONTRACT EDUCATION
UNITS. IF WE ARE FUNDED TO
CONTINUE THIS TYPE OF CRITICAL
TRAINING SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE MEETING TODAY.
NINE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THANK
YOU THIS IS CLAUDIA VK AND I AM
THE ADVOCATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
WOMEN'S BUSINESS CENTER NETWORK
OF SIXTEEN CENTERS SERVING
NINETEEN LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT
OUR STATE. FOURTEEN OF THESE
CENTERS RECEIVED STATE FUNDING
THROUGH THE GOBIZ HATE THAT THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE EXPANSION
PROJECT THAT YOU'RE FAMILIAR
WITH. NOW I KNOW YOU'RE ALL
AWARE OF THE DISPROPORTIONATE
AND NEGATIVE IMPACTS OF THE
PANDEMIC ON WOMEN AND HOW THEY
HAVE BEEN LEAVING THE WORK
FORCE IN DROVES SHOULD TO CARE
FOR CHILDREN- AND TO- YOU KNOW
BASICALLY. TRY TO CREATE INCOME
FROM HOME. BUT WHAT YOU MAY NOT
BE AWARE OF IS THE CRITICAL
ROLE THAT WOMEN'S BUSINESS
CENTERS ARE NOW PLAYING IN
HELPING WOMEN'S BUSINESS OWNERS
READ REPOSITION THEIR
BUSINESSES. GET THE RESOURCES
IN CAPITAL THEY NEED AND THE
TRAINING IN- ONLINE TRAINING
THAT WAS MENTIONED EARLIER TO
IT'S A BIG PIECE OF THAT. AND
ALSO- THEREBY CREATE MORE
HOUSEHOLD INCOME. WE RECENTLY
COLLECTED DATA ON THE IMPACTS
OF FOURTEEN CENTERS IN TWENTY
TWENTY. AND THIS REVEALED A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
SERVICES TO WOMEN OWNED
BUSINESS CHANGE. NINE THOUSAND
BUSINESSES COURSES STAINED
INCLUDING MANY NEWSTART AT. AS
WOMEN OF NECESSITY ARE CREATING
WAYS TO GENERATE NEW INCOME IN
THEIR HOMES. THIS REPRESENTED A
210050% INCREASE OVER LAST
YEAR'S SERVICE FIGURES. THESE
MICRO BUSINESSES GENERATED
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
AND REVENUES. AND THE WOMEN'S
BUSINESS CENTERS LEVERAGED
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS IN NEW
CAPITAL FOR THEIR CLIENTS WHICH
WITH A 120% INCREASE OVER LAST
YEAR SHE- THIS- INCREASE REALLY
RELATE SO MUCH TO WHAT BIANCA
BLANC WHICH WAS TALKING ABOUT
EARLIER IN HER PRESENTATION IS
A CRITICAL NEED A SMALL
BUSINESSES TO HAVE ACCESS TO
CAPITAL NOW. WE ARE REACHING
THE UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES IN
PARTICULAR 53% OF THE PLANS OF
WOMEN'S BUSINESS CENTERS ARE
PEOPLE OF COLOR. IN 55% ARE
FROM LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS-
EARLIER DR FAIRLY MANSION THE
IMPORT MULTIPLIER EFFECT OF
SMALL BUSINESSES SO LET'S%
REMEMBER THAT THE SMALL WOMEN
BUSINESS OWNERS ARE CIRCULATING
THEIR REVENUES MORE THAN TWO
TIMES IN THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. SO WHEN YOU THINK
OF ECONOMIC RECOVERY YOU'VE GOT
TO BE THINKING OF WOMEN
ENTREPRENEURS. WOMEN'S BUSINESS
CENTERS ARE SUPPORTING THESE
ENTREPRENEURS TO SUSTAIN AND
THRIVE DURING THE PANDEMIC YOU
WERE ABLE TO DO THIS BECAUSE OF
AUGMENTED FUNDING FROM THE
CARES FACT IN FROM THE STATE
TAKE FUNDS. BUT A SECURE THAT
FUNDING WINDS DOWN AT THE END
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND WE
WILL BE COMING TO THE STATE
LEGISLATURE FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDS TO CONTINUE CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. THROUGH THE
ROBUST NETWORK OF WOMEN'S
BUSINESS CENTERS. THANKS A LOT.
AT. NINE FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
I'M CALLING IS REPRESENTATIVE
WON'T EVEN CA- MENUS ARE
KEYSTONE BUSINESSES IN
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITIES OUR
ECOSYSTEM DRIVES REVENUE FOR
HOTELS. THAT PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
TANSIT BARS RESTAURANTS RETAIL
AND OTHER SMALL BUSINESSES
CONDITIONALLY INDEPENDENT
VENUES EMPLOYEE CARES UNION
STAGEHANDS JANITORIAL COMMUNITY
SERVICES TRUCK DRIVERS
BARTENDERS TICKET TAKERS
SECURITY LIGHTING AND AUDIO
BUSINESSES AND MANY MORE THINGS
HAVE BEEN CLOSED FOR ALMOST A
YEAR WITH NO REVENUE AND STILL
DO NOT HAVE A TANGIBLE TIMELINE
FOR REOPENING. OR CLOSE THE
BUSINESSES CONTRACTORS AND
WORKERS WE SUPPORT ARE ALSO
ADVERSELY IMPACTED IF WE CLOSE
PERMANENTLY AS KEYSTONES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES CALIFORNIA WILL NOT
ONLY LOSE JOBS AND BUSINESSES
BUT PART OF ITS CULTURAL
IDENTITY AS WELL WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU TO
STABILIZE OUR INDUSTRY TO.
ENSURE OUR WE CAN REOPEN ONE
POSITION THANK YOU A. OF MY TAX.
AT NINE FORTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE AHEAD. YES THANK
YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AT
THIS HEARING MY NAME IS KEY TO
OUR REMOTE AND I'M ALSO
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE NATIONAL
INDEPENDENT THE NEW YORK
LOCATION WHILE WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE SMALL
BUSINESS RELIEF EFFORTS NAMELY
THE LARGE PACKAGE PASSED
RECENTLY. LOCAL BUT NOT MEET
THE NEEDS OF ONE OF THE MOST
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED
INDUSTRIES DURING THE PANDEMIC.
AND THAT IS FOR PROFIT
INDEPENDENT VENUES AND
PROMOTERS. GREAT SIZES ARE TOO
SMALL AND OFTEN DO NOT MEET THE.
EXCLUDES THE WIDE MAJORITY OF
THESE VENUES. WE WERE THE FIRST
TO CLOSE THEN WE WILL BE THE
LAST TO RE OPEN. AND IF THE
SMALL BUSINESS PROGRAM DOES NOT
ADDRESS OUR INDUSTRY IT IS
CLEARLY NOT HITTING THE MARK
FOR THE MOST AFFECTED SECTOR.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATORS ON HOW BEST TO
STABILIZE OUR INDUSTRY AND
PREVENT FURTHER LOSS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME- NINE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES GOOD MORNING-
MADAM CHAIR AND NOT THANK YOU
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TODAY-
DRUG USE ISSUES- MY NAME IS
ROGER CALLING- I REPRESENT I
NEED TO CALIFORNIA WHERE AN
ASSOCIATION OF FIVE HUNDRED
PLUS INDEPENDENT LIVE MUSIC
VENUES AND PROMOTERS OF THESE
ARE FOR PROFIT ARTS AND CULTURE
BUSINESSES AND ARE ANCHOR
TENANTS AND- IN YOUR COMMUNITY.
THAT DRIVE UPWARDS OF THIRTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN ACTIVITY- IT
WAS STATED BEFORE OUTSTANDING
AGAIN WE WERE THE FIRST
BUSINESSES TO CLOSE AND WILL BE
THE VERY LAST TO REOPEN- THAT
IS ZERO REVENUE AND ZERO
CAPACITY- GOING ON TWELVE
MONTHS NOW. VENUES ARE
AVERAGING TWENTY THOUSAND TO
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER MONTH TO REMAIN SHUTTERED
NOW WE'RE STARING DOWN THE
BARREL OF EIGHTEEN MONTHS PLUS
ONE SO WE CAN REOPEN SAFELY
AND- WHILE WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR
THE ATTEMPT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
GRANT RELIEF PROGRAM AT THE
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR CAP
ON GRANT SIZES BARELY COVERS
ONE MONTH OF OVERHEAD COSTS.
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
GROSS REVENUE CAP ALSO RENDERS
MOST VENUES IN ELIGIBLE FOR
THIS PROGRAM. THERE'S ALSO AN
EMPLOYEE RE HIGHER CREDIT
AVAILABLE ON THIS PROGRAM WHICH
DOES NOT WORK FOR OUR ENTIRE
INDUSTRY AS WE ARE NOT WE
HIRING ANY TIME SOON IS THERE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR AN EMPLOYEE
RETENTION CREDIT FOR VENUE
OWNERS THAT HAVE KEPT SOME
PEOPLE ON BOARD TO KEEP FOOD ON.
THE TABLE AND OFF OF
UNEMPLOYMENT. SHE'S NOT
ANCHORED WE TO INTO YOUR
COMMUTE. HOTELS BARS SUBBAN
TRANSPORTATION PARKING METERS
AND RETAIL. BENNY'S EMPLOYS
CATERERS UNION STAGEHANDS
JANITORIAL SERVICES TRUCK
DRIVERS BARTENDERS TICKET
TAKERS SECURITY SERVICES AND
ALL OF THE AUDIO VISUAL VENDORS
THAT MAKE THE MAGIC HAPPEN-
WILL BE SITTING ON THE
SIDELINES WATCHING EVERY OTHER
BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA OPENED
BEFORE WE AS THE LIVE EVENTS
COMMUNITY RE OPEN AND WHILE
WE'RE CLOSE THE BUSINESSES
CONTRACTORS AND WORKERS IN OUR
DECIMATED INDUSTRY WILL ALSO BE
OUT OF BUSINESS- WE TRULY LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
UNTIL WE CAN RETURN TO FULL
CAPACITY ADVANCE- WHEN IT IS
DEEMED SAFE TO DO SO. LIVE
EVENTS AND VENUES AND PROMOTERS
WILL BE CRITICAL TO THE
ECONOMIC SOCIAL AND CULTURAL
RECOVERY IN CALIFORNIA- I THANK
YOU AND YIELD MY TIME. NINE
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS ROBERT I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF LONG BEACH COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT AND THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEGAL CALIFORNIA. I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE NEED
FOR ONGOING COLLECTIBLE
RESOURCES SO THAT DISTRICTS CAN
MEET STUDENT NEEDS AND THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY THANK YOU SIR.
MANY COLLEGES REQUIRE ONGOING.
LOCAL BASE OPERATING DOLLARS
BETWEEN THE CAPACITY TO SERVE
STUDENTS AND OUR COMMUNITIES
THANK YOU. AT NINE FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JUSTIN RATHER CALLING
ON BEHALF OF WORKER OWNED
RECOVERY CALIFORNIA COALITION.
WE ARE A STATEWIDE COALITION
OF. NONPROFITS EXPERIENCE
WORKER OWNED BUSINESSES AND
ORGANIZED LABOR- THAT ARE
SUPPORTING WORKER OWNERSHIP
MODELS IS A VIABLE PATHWAY FOR
RETAINING ARE VERY VALUABLE
SMALL BUSINESSES IN THE STATE-
IN REGARDS TO THE COMMITTEE'S
DISCUSSION AROUND ACCESS TO
CAPITAL- WE DEFINITELY AGREE
AND ACTUALLY HAVE A BUDGET ASK
CIRCULATING. AS WE SPEAK WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING GAUGING
ON HOW WORKER OWNED BUSINESSES
IN THE STATE AND HOW THEY CAN
WE CAN EASE. ACCESS TO CAPITAL
FOR THESE BUSINESSES WHICH ARE.
MAINSTREAM INCORPORATIONS FOR
BUSINESSES THAT JUST HAVE A
DIFFERENT MODEL IN TERMS OF HOW
THEY ARE STRUCTURED- SHAPE THE
CONVERSATION AND LOOK FOR THAT
TO CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE FOR WORKER OWNERSHIP IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. MIND YOU
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA AND
THE EAST BAY VENUE COALITION IN
ALAMEDA COUNTY. THE FOR PROFIT
VENUES AND PROMOTERS ARE ARTS
AND CULTURE BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE BEEN SHATTERED FOR ALMOST
AN ENTIRE YEAR DO GOVERNMENT
MANDATED SHUTDOWN. ZERO REVENUE
FOR ALMOST TWELVE MONTHS MANY
OF THE NON ACCOUNTING ARE
BURNING AN AVERAGE OF SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS EACH MONTH.
JUST TO KEEP OUR BUSINESSES AND
SO WE CAN SAFELY REOPEN. EVEN
IF TAX TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IS NOT ENOUGH TO HELP
BUSINESSES FROM FAILURE. THE
TWO POINT FIVE GROSS REVENUE
CAP ALSO MAKE MOST MENUS AN
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS PROGRAM. MANY
OF THEIR GOOD TENANTS AND
GENERATE REVENUE FOR THE
SURROUNDING ECONOMY. OTHER
STATES HAVE. OTHER STATES HAVE
SEEN THE VALUE OF OUR INDUSTRY
AND PASS ECONOMIC RELIEF TO
KEEP THE INDEPENDENT MENUS A
LOT. ORGAN ALLOCATED TEN
MILLION FOR PROFIT AND
NONPROFIT VENUES. OHIO
ALLOCATED TWENTY MILLION AND
MARILYN ALLOCATED THIRTY
MILLION. CALIFORNIA HAS NOT
DIRECTLY ADDRESSED OUR INDUSTRY
MOST GRANTS FOR THE ARTS ARE
DIRECTED TO NONPROFITS ALL
BUSINESSES IN OUR INDUSTRY HAVE
BEEN AFFECTED AND WILL
DISAPPEAR WITHOUT FINANCIAL
SUPPORT. AT THE CALIFORNIA CHAU
FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR
INDEPENDENT VENUES BEFORE
THEY'RE GONE. THANK YOU. NINE
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ROB READY- AND I'M REPRESENTING.
OF ANY COALITION. THE
INDEPENDENT MANY ALLIANCES
THERE TO GO AND NEED TO
CALIFORNIA- WE NEED CALIFORNIA
REPRESENT ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
DIFFERENT INDEPENDENT VENUES
AND LYFT PROMOTERS- HAVE YOU
HEARD. MANY MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES THE CURRENT PLANS
THE CALIFORNIA HAS TO ADDRESS-
THE LIVE EVENT VENUE INDUSTRY.
JUST WON'T WORK FOR THE
INDUSTRY FOR NUMEROUS REASONS-
SPECIFICALLY THE POINT THAT I
WANTED TO MAKE WITH THAT MANY
OTHER STATES HAVE FIGURED THIS
OUT. AND ALLOCATED- SUBSTANTIAL
SUMS OF MONEY TO HELP THE
INDUSTRY THAT WAS FORCED TO
CLOSE WILL BE A LOT- THOSE
STATES. HAVE GONE FROM AT EIGHT
MILLION TO SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS TOWARDS LIVE NINE YEARS-
AND FOR CALIFORNIA WHERE RENT
IS NOT CHEAP- AND IT MAKES UP A
HUGE HUGE COARSENESS STATE'S
ECONOMY- WE'RE WE'RE EXPECTING
A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
WOULD HELP THE INDUSTRY- AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK YOU'RE
DOING ON THIS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND- WE HAVE TO WORK
THE FURTHER ON THIS MATTER
FAILED MY TIME. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAU TO EACH
OF THAT PROVIDED A PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AND PUBLIC COMMENT
TODAY- WE DO HEAR THOSE
CONCERNS AND CERTAINLY LOOK AT
WHERE WE'RE LOOKING AT WAYS TO
ADDRESS THOSE MOVING FORWARD
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I HOPE
YOU FOUND THIS HEARING TO BE A
SOLID FIRST STEP IN DEVELOPING.
SOUND ECONOMIC POLICIES THAT
CREATED. LIVING WAGE JOBS-
SUPPORT ENTREPRENEURS AND
EXPAND BUSINESS OPPORTUNITIES
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON JOBS I WANT TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
THE EXCELLENT WITNESSES TODAY
AND THE PUBLIC FOR
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S
HEARING. THIS HEARING IS
DOWNTURN.